Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 136. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch alle nach einer etwas ausgedehnten Schöpfungspause hier auf dem Kanal. Denn es gab mal wieder eine Menge zu tun. Wenn man Blog liest, wird wissen, was so vorgefallen ist. Ich will das jetzt hier im Einzelnen gar nicht auseinanderklamm büsern. Trotzdem, es geht jetzt weiter. Nachdem ich mir in der Zwischenzeit ein kleines Podcast-Studio eingerichtet habe, das ist wie alles im Leben ein fortlaufender Prozess. Und jetzt sitzen wir hier auch gerade in einer kleinen Runde und schütteln gemeinsam den Kopf, wie diese ganze Musiktechnik dann doch in entscheidendem Moment immer andere Dinge tut, als man das eigentlich gerade selber möchte. So ist das nämlich, wenn man sich hier so basteltechnisch damit beschäftigt. Und im weiteren Sinne tangiert das heutige Thema auch genau diesen Bereich. Aber es geht nicht so sehr um Radio. Es geht eigentlich auch nicht unbedingt jetzt so sehr um Musik, aber im weiteren Sinne schon. Aber grundsätzlich möchte ich hier ein kleines Kulturphänomen mal realisieren, denn heute geht es schlicht um Techno. Und dazu begrüße ich Tanith. Ja, Tanith, das finde ich super, dass das geklappt hat. Und vielleicht mal mit dir ein bisschen anfangen, wenn wir dich nicht unbedingt alle Leute kennen, aber ein bisschen bekannt bist du schon, denn du ziehst ja schon eigentlich seit langer Zeit deine Kreise in der deutschen Kulturlandschaft.
Ja, besonders halt in der Techno-Landschaft.
Vor allem in der Techno-Landschaft, genau. Das heißt, du bist bekannt als DJ, du bist bekannt als Musikmacher und du bist auch im Netz recht aktiv. Seit wann, weiß ich nicht, wann ist denn so das Thema Musik auf dich zugekommen in deinem Leben?
Na, das fing ja schon sehr früh an. Also ich meine, ich bin Lehrerssohn und du musst dich immer irgendwie von den Pädagogen irgendwie so distanzieren und das machst du halt in deiner frühen Jugend halt über Musik. Und das hat bei mir mit zwölf, mit Alice Cooper angefangen, ging weiter über KISS und 1977 gab es dann Punk.
Also du hast ja gleich die schlecht geschminkten, irgendwie schlecht gekleideten, dunklen Gestalten ausgesucht.
Na klar, das hat damals die Pädagogen auch am meisten geschockt. Ja, dann kam Punk und...
Damals war, was jetzt? Wir reden von Ende 70er-Jahre.
Ende 70er-Jahre.
Das war so die heiße Teenie-Phase bei dir.
Ja, da war ich genau im richtigen Alter für so was.
Da gab es noch Hitparade im Fernsehen.
Disco mit den Herr Richter.
Das darf er eigentlich nicht sagen, aber ich fand es toll.
Ja, und dann ging das halt weiter. Punk wurde ja dann irgendwann sehr stereotyp. Also man musste halt die Leder ja getragen und den Ero tragen, sonst war mal kein Punk. Und dann wurde das auch schon eigentlich wieder uninteressant. Aber zur gleichen Zeit gab es dann halt so Sachen wie Robin Grizzle, Cabaret Voltaire und so weiter. Die halt irgendwie diese Punk-Idee, die dann ja irgendwann sehr standardisiert war.
Was ist die Punk-Idee?
Die Punk-Idee sind drei Akkorde, rotzfrech sein und auf dem Platz rumhängen und alte Leute schockieren eigentlich. Das war unser Spaß damals. Und das war dann irgendwann auch irgendwie so ein bisschen langweilig geworden. Also man wollte es auf eine andere Ebene heben und das ging halt eigentlich nur noch über die Elektronik. Weil im Punk war dann auch irgendwann so, hat man festgestellt, naja gut, das war jetzt was Iggy und des Dudes oder so was früher auch schon gemacht haben. Haben wir dann einfach noch auf ein anderes Level gehoben. Aber das war dann auch sehr schnell die Grenzen ausgelotet. So fand ich damals. Und mit der Elektronik, das war dann so 79, 80, als dann so die ersten Sachen kamen, so SPK Leichenschrei zum Beispiel war.
Was? SPK Leichenschrei?
Ja, das ist eine australische Band, also das ist Creme Revell, der macht heute so Soundtracks für die großen Hollywood-Filme. Aber der hatte angefangen mit Industrial und eine prägende Scheibe war für mich halt zum Beispiel, nebens Robin Grissl hießen Earth, SPK Leichenschrei. Und das Cover sah auch genauso aus, wie es hieß.
Also deutscher Name, australische Leute.
Ja, die sind dann aber glaube ich nach England gezogen, also wo diese ganze Industrial-Szene da existierte. Oder dann gab es auch, was dann später in Techno Sheffield wurde, Cabaret Voltaire kamen auch aus Sheffield. Jume League, oder es gab auch diesen Popsektor Jume League, Heaven 17 und so weiter. Das war dann eigentlich so diese Ebene, wo man sagen konnte, also das war für mich schon Techno, ohne dass es Techno gab. Aber ich habe das damals schon gehört und habe seitdem eigentlich immer an diesem Strang geforscht. Was kann man mit Elektronik machen? Tanzbar, auch teilweise untanzbar.
Aber welche Bedeutung hatte denn elektronische Musik Ende der 70er Jahre? Ich meine, was gab es denn da? Da gab es auch eigentlich nur Kraftwerk.
Nee, da gab es auch schon Ende der 70er Jahre, gab es auch schon Hip-Hop eigentlich. Da gab es Grandmaster Flash. Es gab hier diese ganzen Krautrock-Jungs, die auch da versucht haben, Elektronik mit dem Rock einzubauen. Es gab schon eine Menge Versuche, aber die waren halt alle nicht wirklich... Also im Nachhinein gesehen für mich eher langweilig.
Also meine elektronische Musik, reden wir von elektronischer Musik oder reden wir von Musik mit elektronischen Musikinstrumenten?
Das war schon elektronische Musik. Hör dir mal zum Beispiel Klaus Schulze an oder sowas. Das gab es auch schon in der 70er. Oder so Bands wie Grobschnitt oder sowas. Die hatten zwei Gitarren und sowas drin, aber die waren so mit Effekten beladen und sowas.
Okay, aber wenn es zu dem Zeitpunkt schon alles Mögliche gab, wann gab es denn mal nichts? Wo siehst du denn jetzt im Rückblick die Ursprünge der elektronischen Musik?
Die Ursprünge? Der Ursprung schlechthin ist eigentlich dieses Stück Popcorn. Das war das erste Stück elektronischer Musik, das auch im Radio gelaufen ist.
Das war so 1974 oder so.
Ja, 1974 so.
Ich kann mich noch erinnern. Als kleines Kind war ich irgendwie im Urlaub und es lief nichts anderes. Stimmt.
Und das war für mich. Da würde ich jetzt bei mir ansetzen und sagen, da fängt jetzt elektronische Musik eigentlich für mich an. Also da ist zum ersten Mal durch elektronische Musik aufmerksam wurde. Vorher hast du eigentlich nur immer Gitarren, Rock und sowas gehört. Und das war zum ersten Mal, wo man dann so irgendwie gehört hat, es war zwar irgendwie so ein Gimmickstück irgendwie, das hätte auch später Tetris sein können. Aber es war das erste Mal, dass ein voll elektronisches Stück eine Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hatte, mainstreamig.
Stimmt.
Und von da aus ging es halt weiter.
Ich meine, du kannst Kraftwerk nicht einfach außen vor lassen. Dass die zu den Pionieren gehören, denke ich, lässt dich nicht bestreiten?
Nee, das lässt sich natürlich nicht bestreiten. Aber die hatten ja auch eigentlich unelektronisch angefangen.
Ja, so mit Geigen und Tralala hatten da so ihre Komposition. Und was hat dann, weißt du, was da umgeschaltet hat bei denen?
Was ist da passiert?
Ja, was ist da auf einmal los? Die guten Jungs, auf einmal schmeißen sie ihre Musikinstrumente weg und machen irgendwie alles mit der Maschine.
Ich habe das jetzt nicht so verfolgt, weil Kraftwerk fand ich zwar immer toll, aber war jetzt nicht unbedingt das, was mich jetzt so besonders berührt hat, außer...
Aber die waren es natürlich schon bis heute diejenigen, die das auch kulturell, ich sage jetzt mal technokulturell, auch voll gelebt haben. So dieses, wir sind die Roboter, wir sind irgendwie die moderne Zeit, voll automatisierte Konzerte, bis sie dann irgendwie auch verschwinden und auf einmal durch ihrem Roboter abgelöst werden. Alles läuft voll automatisch durch. Und man fragt sich das erste Mal im Leben, wozu sind Konzerte eigentlich jetzt noch da, wenn das eh alles nur noch irgendwie von der Playback-Taste kommt. Das fand ich persönlich immer extrem erstaunlich, dass sie einfach genau mit diesem Ding auch soweit gespielt haben, bis sozusagen auch ihre eigenen Selbste da komplett sich auflösen.
Ja, aber das war mir jetzt, also ich finde das, ich finde eigentlich Schäches daran, aber es war nicht das, was mich an elektronischer Musik so fasziniert hat. Also ich fand die toll, aber ich fand eigentlich die Verwurstung, die dann später zum Beispiel auch durch den Grandmaster Flash kam, eigentlich besser. Also das damals schon gemäschert wurde sozusagen.
Was hat der da verwurstet?
Der hat die Beats zum Beispiel von was, ich weiß nicht, Numbers oder sowas, Nummern, alles was genommen und dann halt da drüber irgendwie gescratcht und sowas. Das war doch, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, wie das Stück hieß irgendwie. Auf jeden Fall hat er diese ganze Elektroschiene damals, also diese Originalelektro, das hat ja alles auf Kraftwerk beruht, hatte aber mehr Beef. Also was mir bei Kraftwerk immer gefehlt hat, war irgendwie so, das war halt schon sehr leiseträterische, schöne Musik und mir hat immer so ein bisschen das Dreck gefehlt.
Ja, symphonisch, kann man fast sagen.
Ja, auch alles sehr sauber halt. Und dann höre ich nebendran so Cabaret Voltaire irgendwie und da ist halt dieser menschliche Dreck noch mit drin. Und der interessiert mich, also mich interessiert nicht irgendwie diese rein technisierte Form, sondern halt auch diese Hybriden, die da draußen stehen. Aber da kann auch mal ruhig ne Gitarre drin sein oder Kraftwerk war am Anfang halt auch nur Synthesizer und nebendran wurde dann schon probiert mit Sampling auch zu arbeiten. Weil ich halt auch persönlich sehr wichtig finde, dass Sampling ist ne Technik, die Techno auch erst möglich gemacht hat eigentlich. Und das kam bei Kraftwerk auch vor, aber dann auch wieder in so einer cleanen, sterilen, klinischen Weise irgendwie.
Es sind ja auch mehr eigentlich die Synthetischen. Das sind eigentlich erstmal diejenigen, die den UR-Synthesizer-Klang ja überhaupt erstmal erforscht und zur Anwendung gebracht haben und ihm auch so eine eigene Ästhetik damit verdienen haben und damit erstmal gearbeitet haben. Während dann die anderen irgendwie zunehmend in dieses Recycling reingekommen sind.
Ich mein, sie haben auch in der Rhythmik schon einiges geschaffen. Also die elektronische Rhythmik ist ja auch, man kann schon sagen, dass Krachtwerk Pioniere waren, aber halt Pioniere, die mich jetzt nicht hauptsächlich inspiriert haben.
Welche Pioniere haben dich inspiriert?
Na ja, so Cabaret Voltaire, Saubingrissl, SBK, was gab's dann später noch, auch später so Sachen Nitsa-App, die auch eigentlich am Anfang abklatscht von DAF waren.
Wo hast du denn das gehört? Im Radio lief das ja nicht.
Nee, ich war da schon immer Forscher. Es gab damals so einen Plattenladen in Bonn, normal, da war ich schon bekannt, da hab ich immer einmal im Monat Platten bestellt.
Da kommste her?
Nee, da komm ich nicht her, ich komm aus der Ecke Wiesbaden eigentlich.
Achso, man muss aber immer nach Bonn fahren, damit...
Nee, ich hab das alles per Telefon gemacht. Die mussten mir das dann vorspielen, über Telefon. Und dann kannten sie irgendwann meinen Geschmack. Und meinten auch schon, hier ist es.
Nein, du hast da angerufen und die haben dann den Telefonhörer irgendwie an die Box gehalten? Ah, verstehe, das ist so Früh-Internet sozusagen.
Ja, so mit Review-Taste. Ja, dann so lief das damals. Guck mal, hier ist die neue Weithaus, hör dir das mal an, du hast eine Krach gehört, weil da auf der Platte auch eine Krach drauf war irgendwie. Weithaus war weit Neues eigentlich. Und dann hast du gesagt, oh ja, geil, ja, hammer, ja, die kannst du gleich dazu packen. Und irgendwann so nach einem halben, dreiviertel Jahr kannten die halt meinen Geschmack irgendwie. Und dann ging das eigentlich recht flott. Hier eine neue Weithaus, hier eine neue Merzbau, hier eine neue, was weiß ich, 23Skidoo.
Sind wir jetzt immer noch am Ende der 70er?
Ja, ist Anfang 80er.
Aha, Discordia.
Weiß nicht, ob das Discordia nennt. Also das Wort hat ja irgendwie eine vielfache Bedeutung.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen Slang. Dann gibt es diese Band. Naja, ich meine, wo die 23 drin ist, ist die 23 drin. Aber das ist in der Tat was sehr Altes. Das muss ich jetzt selber erstmal nachlesen. Wie auch immer, bleiben wir erstmal bei dem Bestellung der Musik. Jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, irgendwie Industrial kam auf. Man muss ja sagen, das Wort Techno gab es nicht.
Nee, das gab es noch weit von entfernt.
Ganz weit von entfernt, aber es gab schon Industrial. Und wie würdest du beschreiben, was Industrial ist?
Electropunk. Eigentlich die Urform von elektronischem Punk. Das war eine sehr experimentelle Musik, die dann aber auch sehr ausgeufert ist, genauso wie Techno später auch. Das Phänomen bei elektronischer Musik ist ja, dass es irgendwie mit einem Punkt anfängt und von da aus Äste treibt bis zum geht nicht mehr. Also Industrial ist dann irgendwann ein bisschen die Neo-Fork-Ecke mit Death in June oder so, hat alles vorgedrungen. Das hat dann irgendwie wenig noch mit Elektronik zu tun gehabt, sondern eigentlich nur noch so ein runen, rauenes Gitarrengedudel irgendwie. Warum nennt man es denn Industrial? Weil die ganzen Leute irgendwie aus dem gleichen Stamm angefangen hatten damals. Alle hatten ursprünglich mit Elektronik zu tun gehabt. Elektronik war ja damals noch was Besonderes. Heute ist es ja keine Erwähnung mehr wert, beziehungsweise manche erwähnen dann doch lieber gar nicht. Ich meine, jeder Rock-Ecke heute ist elektronisch. Aber damals war das halt noch was Besonderes. Es gab halt nur ein paar Rhythmusboxen, es gab ein paar Synthesizer, es gab dieses Fairlight Monster, es gab ein bisschen später dann noch diese Emu-Sampler, die dann erschwinglich wurden. Aber zu der Zeit Anfang 80er, da gab es nichts. Robin Grizzel hat damals ihre elektronischen Instrumente selber zusammengelötet. Das war damals auch was Besonderes. Also das waren Sachen, die man damals noch nicht gehört hatte. Und das war das, was auch die Elektronik ausgemacht hatte, dass man halt irgendwie neue Soundkosmen aufgestoßen hat. An die Gitarre war ja irgendwie klar, du konntest noch einen Flanger dranhängen, du konntest noch eine Distortion dranhängen und so was. Aber irgendwann war es irgendwie, du hast immer noch die Gitarre ausgehört. Bei der Elektronik war es dann irgendwann, dass du halt irgendwie vergleiche Klaus Schulze mit White House zum Beispiel. Was da schon der eine halt voll symphonisch oder Jean-Michel Jarre gab es ja auch schon in den 70ern irgendwie. Und dagegen dann Robin Gherisel. Also du hast einerseits diese schönmalerische Synthesizer, auf der anderen Seite irgendwie den vollen Dreck. Also so richtig so, naja, Leichenschrei sagt es halt schon. Der Untertitel war Can the Earth be a Sad as it seems? Zum Beispiel. Also das waren halt diese extremen Gegensätze. Einmal diese schönmalerische Synthesizer und hier Orgel und Bach hätte sich wahrscheinlich einen runtergeholt, wenn er das gehabt hätte. Und auf der anderen Seite hast du halt irgendwie dieses Low-Tech-Zeug irgendwie selbst zusammengelötet und daraus irgendwie eine Musik gemacht, die vorher vielleicht noch gar nicht als Musik akzeptiert gewesen wäre.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen die Klaviaturschläge zurück, nicht wahr? Also nachdem so mit Rock irgendwie so die Gitarre eigentlich so zu dem dominanten Gestaltungsmusikinstrument aufgestiegen ist, neben dem Schlagzeug vielleicht, kam dann auf einmal mit dem Klavier, also mit dem Synthesizer sozusagen wurde das Klavier wieder hochfähig und...
Na die Tastatur, die war ja, ich mein, das war ja auch das Schöne, weißt du, bei Punk musstest du noch drei Akkorde lernen. Bei der Elektronik noch nicht mal mehr das. Du hattest einfach nur dein, was war das damals, ein Minimug zum Beispiel, hattest da eine Kabel gesteckt, irgendwie hast du versucht, den Sequencer irgendwie zum Laufen zu kriegen oder eine SH-101 von Roland und so, hast dann versucht, irgendwie da Töne rauszukriegen und damals vielleicht noch mit dem Vierspur-Kassettenrekorder irgendwie dann Vierspuren irgendwie Lärm zusammen zu mixen, dass am Schluss irgendwie eine Kackophonie rauskam, die irgendwas im Kopf bewirkt.
Was ist denn eigentlich so die Essenz des Synthesizers? Hast du mit diesen alten Geräten auch noch gearbeitet?
Ich war ja nie so, also ich meine, es ist nicht umsonst so, dass ich zum DJing gekommen bin, weil ich bin eher so der Verwurster fertiger Sachen. Also ich sample gerne ab und verarbeite das neu. Und der Synthesizer war mir immer, bis er da bei einem Ergebnis ist, das hat mir immer zu lange gedauert.
Das ist schon so ein bisschen was für diese Klangfeingeister.
Ja, so diese ganzen Sound-Designer-Leute und so weiter. Also die halt genau wissen, wenn ich den LFO hier mit dem verbinde und das und das. Das ist mir dann zu vielschichtig. Ich will auch Ergebnisse sehen oder hören. Ich habe mich lange damit auseinandergesetzt, aber ich habe halt immer festgestellt, es ist nicht unbedingt mein Metier.
Na gut, bleiben wir nicht so sehr bei den Synthesisern hängen. Ich wollte ja erst mal ein bisschen auf diese kulturelle Timeline, um einfach mal so ein bisschen zu verstehen, wie es dazu kam. Weil um es auch ein bisschen vorwegzunehmen, in meiner simplen Wahrnehmung, ich denke, so sehen das viele Leute auch. Es gab so die Uhrzeit, was weiß ich, irgendwann kam dann Rock'n'Roll, sozusagen als Metabegriff für eine ganze Generation neuer Musik. Und dieser Oberbegriff hat dann eigentlich für 20, 30 Jahre auch die populäre Musik weitgehend bestimmt. Das war einfach der Mainstream. Auch das allgemeine Klangempfinden, was sozusagen populäre Musik sein kann, lag irgendwie immer noch da. Da gibt es natürlich unzählige Varianten und man könnte jetzt Musikzähle wahrscheinlich aufzählen mehr als es irgendwie Fachbegriffe im Computerbereich gibt. Aber das Ganze kam dann für mich sozusagen später dann mit Techno zu einem Ende. Man könnte sagen, okay, alles klar, Rock'n'Roll ist jetzt nicht weg. Aber es gibt jetzt eine weitere große Blase, die genauso diffus beschrieben wird mit einem einzigen Begriff und die heißt irgendwie Techno. Techno hat irgendwie das Erbe angetreten, was irgendwie Rock'n'Roll da mal aufgebaut hat. Also das ist jetzt so meine Wahrnehmung. Das kannst du ja auch gerne noch ein bisschen aus deiner Perspektive schildern. Aber deswegen interessiert mich halt einfach, was sozusagen dazu geführt hat. Es muss ja vieles dazukommen. Es muss ja einerseits auch so eine gewisse klangliche Frustration sein bei den Leuten, dass sie irgendwie was anderes hören wollen. Und vor allem muss ja auch gesellschaftlich und insofern auch jetzt global gesellschaftlich da ja auch irgendwie dieses Bedürfnis irgendwie auch einen Grund haben.
Ja, da gab es verschiedene Faktoren, die dazu geführt haben. Also wenn man jetzt das Revue passieren lässt, ist es gar nicht mal so außergewöhnlich und ungewöhnlich. Du hattest in den 70ern schon Disco. Es hat sich in den 80ern weiterentwickelt. Also es gab Diskotheken, richtige Diskotheken, wo halt jedes Wochenende Musik gespielt wurde. Und da gab es auch Diskotheken, die elektronische Musik gespielt haben, wie zum Beispiel der Techno-Club in Frankfurt mit Talla, damals so diese ganzen Front-2-for-2-Sachen oder so was. Was ja im Grunde schon so eine Vorstufe von Techno eigentlich war. Und es gab auch dieses Industrielzeug, das irgendwie, wo viele Musiker halt irgendwie, also sehr viele kreative Köpfe drin waren. Also zum Beispiel, da gab es eine Combo aus England, Greater Than One, die sehr industriell mäßig waren, Mitte der 80er. Und dann kam halt diese Hauswelle aus Amerika, House, Acid, irgendwie so. Und das ist ja dann teilweise in diesen gleichen Diskotheken gelaufen, wo auch dann diese Front-2-for-2-Sachen gelaufen sind. Oder in Belgien gab es dann dieses New Beat, das war dann noch tanzbarerer Front-2-for-2-Kram. Front-2-for-2 war EBM, Electronic Body Music. Das war so die Vorstufe. Es gab ja schon Zentren, wo solche Musik in Diskotheken gespielt wurde. Und dann kam dieses aus Amerika, dieses Haus aus Chicago und Detroit. Also ich hab das zum ersten Mal gehört, 85, 86, dieses House Nation zum Beispiel. Kennt bestimmt jeder. Wurde nur abgesehen mit House Nation. Das war dann in diesem Kontext mit Front-2-for-2, Netlabels und solchen Sachen auch schon gelaufen. Und dann kam Acid und das wurde halt zu einem Hype. Angefangen hat das mit Future Acid Tracks, 86, 87. Wurde auch wieder in Diskotheken gespielt. Und dann kam dieser Acid Hype. Plötzlich war das ja überall in den Medien. Acid gehabt irgendwie, kommt aus England, großer neuer Trend, alle so, ach, das ist ein Jahr vorbei.
In welchen Medien?
Oh, das ging von Bild bis Stern. Ernsthaft? Ja, doch, das kam überall vor. Also das sind in England irgendwie alle jetzt mit Smilies rumlaufen und neue Mode. Ja, und das kam ja dann auch in die Hitparade, so Mars, Pump Up the Volume oder so was. War ja dann auch so 87, 88 schon in Charts gewesen. Und dann, muss man halt sagen, haben die Drogen halt noch mitgespielt. Da sind die Engländer halt nach Ibiza geflogen, haben da ihre Assets eingeschmissen oder ihre Ehes. Und das hat natürlich dann, wie immer bei der Musik, die passende Droge, mit der passenden Musik, macht dann so eine Sache irgendwie, wo man sich dann wundert, was da für Energien frei werden.
Wie schon bei den Hippies seinerzeit mit dem Rock'n'Roll. Ich meine, so Woodstock und so weiter ist ja auch nicht möglich gewesen, glaube ich, ohne einen nennenswerten Drogenkonsum. Beim Haus wollte ich noch mal kurz einhaken, bevor wir jetzt sozusagen wirklich jetzt hier so den Entstehungspunkt von Techno verorten. Ich weiß da gar nicht so viel drüber, aber du hast ja schon gesagt, Chicago, die treut. Meines Wissens war das vor allem ja auch ein Produkt der Schulen-Szene sozusagen, die sich dort auch einer gewissen Unterdrückung entzogen haben und dann Partys zu Hause gemacht haben. Deswegen der Name Haus.
Das war eigentlich Warehouse, das war die Diskothek, aber das war nicht rein schwul.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es rein schwul war. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass das dann eine Rolle gespielt hat. Die Geschichte kennst du so nicht. Das ist ein bisschen Hörensagen. Deswegen hinterfrag ich das jetzt gerade.
Ich meinte, das ging aus von diesem Warehouse in Chicago.
Ach, das war diese Location, ne? Genau.
Und da wurden halt diese ersten Sachen gespielt, die einfach nur Rhythmus waren.
Du meinst also, dass der Ort der Musik quasi den Namen gegeben hat?
Dann gab es noch Paradise Garage. Deswegen gibt es auch Garage-Musik. Und in Detroit war es halt irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, gab es ja irgendwie die Clubs zu der Zeit, aber da war es diese Electrifying Mojo, der halt irgendwie so diese verschiedene Musikstile miteinander gemixt hat.
Aber das war jetzt sozusagen Mitte der 80er Jahre?
Mitte der 80er, ja.
Und das schwappte dann aber irgendwie nach Britannien rüber?
Ja, da gab es auch Labels, die halt diese Sachen lizenziert hatten aus Amerika. Da gab es halt Transmart Label, PMS Label, DJ International aus Chicago. Die wurden dann teilweise in England aufgrund dieses Asset Hypes irgendwie auch nochmal released. Und damit kamen die dann halt auch nach Europa. Das war so meine Wahrnehmung. Also es gab halt immer diese Exportplatten, die extrem teuer waren in den 80ern. Also da hast du dann für eine Maxi, für die du damals irgendwie acht Mark bezahlt hattest, hat es dann für den amerikanischen Import 16 bezahlt. Da stand dann auch noch mehr drauf, vom großen Only for DJs. Und die waren halt extrem teuer. Und in dem Moment, wo die halt damals, konnte man ja noch Platten verkaufen, im Gegensatz zu heute, wurden die dann in anderen Ländern dezensiert nur dadurch entsprechend billiger, so dass die halt auch oder Sampler, es gab dann auch gleich Haus-Sampler irgendwie, 87, 88. Diese ganzen DJ-International-Sachen gab es dann auch auf Samplern und so. Und haben dadurch dann halt irgendwie auch so diesen Siegeszug nach Europa angetreten.
Und die ganzen ausschwemmenden Briten, die irgendwie Ibiza dann überfüllt haben, haben dann sozusagen dazu beigetragen, dass diese Partykultur auch sich mit ausgebreitet hat. Dieser Name Rave?
Der kommt eigentlich auch aus dem Englischen.
Kommt von daher, ne?
Die sind halt raus auf die Felder, haben da ein Soundsystem aufgebaut. In England gab es ja immer schon erstens Piratenradio. Das ist da sehr wichtig gewesen. Und zum zweiten halt auch diese Reggae-Soundsystems. Die hatten also schon eh Soundsysteme, mit denen sie auch einfach raus aufs Land fahren konnten. Und dann haben sie halt da einen Rave abgefeiert. Und die Dinger, das hat man dann ein paar Jahre versetzt auch hier gehabt. Du hast einfach so was Mundpropagandamäßig rausgegeben und plötzlich standen da 4.000 Leute. Hab ich halt aus England mitgekriegt. Die hatten ja irgendwie, was weiß ich, irgendwo draußen auf dem Acker gefeiert hat mit ein paar Hundert gerechnet. Das waren da 4.000 Leute.
Weil es sich einfach rumgesprochen hat. Weil es wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie einen unglaublichen, wie soll ich sagen, Ventilbedarf gab in der Gesellschaft. In meinen Britten sind ja auch immer sehr bekannt dafür, dass dann auch immer gleich besonders exzessiv aussehen. Man, es gab ja dann später sogar eine Gesetzgebung, die versucht hat, diese Raves, diese Open-Air-Raves zu verbieten. Ich weiß nicht, wie erfolgreich sie war, aber es ging dann wirklich so absurderweise mit, ja, wenn da repetitive Rhythmen gespielt werden und so. Ich weiß nicht, wie hieß denn nochmal gleich diese Akte? Die haben da immer so putzige Namen dafür. Auf jeden Fall ging das richtig heiß her mit irgendwie Helikopter-Rates, um irgendwie diese Parties irgendwie aufzulösen. Weil das echt richtig krasse Dimensionen angenommen hat.
Was Jahre vorher noch super ging, also ich war zum ersten Mal 92 auf so einen Riesen-Ref da nach England gebucht worden. Und das war super. Also hier hatten wir halt irgendwie, so derzeit hatten wir hier halt Love Parade. Wann war das?
87?
Ne, 92 da.
92 schon, okay.
Also da war das hier halt irgendwie, wir hatten Love Parade mit sagen wir mal 10.000 Leuten oder so was. Und dann wirst du nach England gebucht auf so einen Ref irgendwie mit fünf Zelten irgendwie von, ich weiß nicht, was war da alles, von Hauszelt über so Mainstream-ig irgendwie mit einer Achterbahn drauf. Also wo du da hingekommen bist und erstmal nur mit den Augen geschluckert hast, dann gabs dieses Mega-Ding irgendwie. Und dann ein Jahr später wurde es halt alles verboten. Obwohl das Ding völlig legal damals lief. Hatten wir dann ja später auch als Manege von oder so was, oder Sonne, Mond, Sterne heute hier ist, noch größer als das, was damals in England war. Aber halt zum ersten Mal sowas zu sehen, du kommst hier, du bist froh, dass du hier Tresur und E-Werk hattest und so was, dann kommst du auf so ein Ding und schon kilometerweise Staus mit Autos. Was ist denn hier passiert irgendwie? Hast du mal gesehen, wie groß sowas werden kann?
Und trotzdem war Ende der 80er Jahre diese ganze, ich sag mal mal, elektronische Kulturbewegung war irgendwie noch komplett unter dem Radar des Mainstreams in jeder Hinsicht.
Ja, zum Glück. Dadurch konnte es sich noch entwickeln. Also es wurde halt eher so belächelt. Wenn du das in den Medien gesehen hast, war halt immer so, was haben sich da jetzt wieder ausgedacht? Na, lass mal näher gehen, dann ist es wieder vorbei. Dann kommen wir wieder mit unseren Gitarren vor und so was. Das war halt damals der Konsens, wenn du Musikzeitschriften gelesen hast, lass die Kids mal sich austoben mit ihren Smilies. So ein englischer Hype, der in einem Jahr wieder vorbei ist. Das war eigentlich ein Glück gewesen, dass das so unterschätzt wurde. Man hat es bei diesem Asset Hype ja schon gemerkt. Das wurde hochgeputscht und plötzlich gab es von jedem Scheißstück ein Acid Remix, wo der Rhythmus genommen wurde und dann eine 303 dazu quietschte. Das waren ja 88 Usus eigentlich. Da gab es von jedem Scheiß auch noch ein Acid Remix.
Die TB-303 von Roland, so ein kleines unscheinbares Plastikgerät, ist ja fast das berühmteste Stück Synthesizer-Hardware, was die Zeit hervorgebracht hat, kann man sagen.
Zu der Zeit gab es es ja nicht mehr. Das war ja dann da nicht mehr richtig käuflich zu erwerben.
Das war eine alte Scheiße sozusagen.
Das war so eine Bassbegleitung aus den Anfang der 80er, die Roland rausgebracht hatte und das damals genial gefloppt ist eigentlich, weil jeder hat halt gedacht, eine Bassbegleitung klingt wie Bass, aber das Ding klang halt überhaupt nicht wie Bass. Auch die Programmierung von dem Teil...
Also wie ein Gitarrenbass sozusagen.
Und auch die Programmierung von dem Teil war jetzt nicht wirklich simpel gewesen. Und dann kam halt dieser DJ, ich glaube, es war DJ Peer aus Chicago, und hat das Ding halt irgendwie so als Synthesizer benutzt. Dann hat er halt diese Quietschgeräusche daraus geholt.
Und auch eher live?
Auch live, ja. Er hat einfach eine Rhythmospur laufen lassen und hat dazu rumgequietscht irgendwie. Und dann gab es halt auch die ersten Platten, diese Future-Sachen, We Are Future, wie die ganzen Damen Creator und wie die ganzen Sachen damals alle hießen irgendwie. Da gab es noch andere, die dann auch darauf aufgesetzt haben, dazugehörte dann noch die 909 oder die 808 als Rhythmusgerät. Die konnte man auch schön miteinander sinken. Das war halt alles Ronan intern irgendwie. Das waren dann die ersten Asset-Tracks gewesen. Und das war halt damals irgendwie, also wenn man so was heute hört, ist es halt auch nichts mehr Besonderes. Genauso wie es wahrscheinlich heute auch, zum Beispiel, ich den Beatles-Hype nie verstanden habe, obwohl ich in der Zeit groß geworden bin. Aber Leute, die da wahrscheinlich so was damals zum ersten Mal mit einer gewissen musikalischen Sozialisation so was zum ersten Mal gehört haben, für die war das wahrscheinlich eine Offenbarung. Und genauso war das für mich irgendwie, der vorher mit diesem ganzen komplizierten Elektronikkram zu tun hatte, also wo es teilweise sehr verkopft war. Und plötzlich kommt da ein Rhythmus mit Gequietsche und hat so eine Atmosphäre, dass du denkst, boah, genau, so, ohne den ganzen Kopf irgendwie, sondern einfach nur dieses Gequietsche und der Rhythmus, das ist die Zukunft. Das klang nach Zukunft.
Ja, das kann ich extrem gut nachvollziehen. Als das so damals irgendwie so abging, da saß ich irgendwie noch in meinem kleinen, verschlafenen Hannover und kriegte irgendwie von einem nicht so richtig was mit. Und war dann aber auch mal auf Berlin-Besuch und bin dann irgendwie mal rein zufällig ins UFO irgendwie reingekullert, was so damals einer der...
Meine Anfangsstätte.
Deine Anfangsstätte war? Okay. Also noch im Westen, am Winterfeldplatz?
Ja, am Gleispark.
Das erste war in der Köpenicker Straße. Das war ein Keller unter einem Wohnhaus. Für Platz mit 150 Leuten. Da war oben drüber das Büro von Dimitri Hegemann, der heute auch den Tresor macht. Und unten drunter in dem Keller, da war so eine Luke, da haben wir dann ein paar Gitarren-Ems reingestellt, da die Plattenspiele angeschlossen, dann irgendwie so eine Lava-Lampe, also diese, die gebeamt hat, Nebel reingeblasen und das war der erste Eskladen-Club.
Den noch gar keiner mitbekommen hat.
150 Leute damals.
Und der ist dann noch weitergezogen?
Der muss ja, das ist dann irgendwann entdeckt worden, irgendwie muss er weiterziehen, hatten dann so einen geschlossenen Penny-Markt am Kleistpark. Und das war dann das zweite UFO gewesen. Da war halt der Nachteil, dass halt irgendwie die Entlüftungsentlage durch dieses ganze Hochhaus bei den ganzen Mietern vorbeiging und wenn die besser richtig reingedreht hast, es gab immer Beschwerden. Und Techno ohne Bass ist halt kein Techno.
Also das erste Mal so in so einer Techno-Klangwolke drinsteigen, da war das für mich auch so, genau wie du es eben beschrieben hast, ich dachte mir so, was ist das denn jetzt irgendwie, man merkt irgendwie gar nicht, was passiert, auf einmal tanzt man, so, ich dachte mir so unglaublich. Dann kam ich irgendwie wieder zurück nach Hannover und versuchte dann irgendwie stundenlang in irgendwelchen Platten- Läden diese Musik zu finden. Internet gab es nicht. Und natürlich nichts zu holen, so. Und dann wartet ich irgendwie immer so da drauf, dass es mal vorbeikam, so um die Ecke, so eine Techno-Night angekündigt wurde, voller Erwartung da, irgendwelchen kleinen Kombos zuschaute, wie sie an ihren Geräten rumdrehten und irgendwie vergeblich versuchten, irgendwie diesen Beat da rauszukriegen. Dass es dann mal einem wirklich gelungen ist. Und auf einmal wackelte dann auch gleich der ganze Laden, waren nicht viele Leute da, so 40 Leute vielleicht, so. Und in dem Moment merkte ich, wie sie sich auch alle so wieder so angucken, sie so, was war das denn jetzt so? Und dann schwarte mir das erste Mal so, oh weia, das kann doch mal richtig nach hinten losgehen. Das wird irgendwie alles überrollen. Und ja, ein paar Jahre später stand ich dann irgendwie auf der Lafayette und dachte mir so, jetzt ist es passiert. Jetzt tanzen sie alle danach. Und so ging es halt vielen Leuten an. Das muss ja dieser Beatles-Effekt gewesen sein und ich glaube auch Elvis Presley dürfte mal ähnliche Ergebnisse erzielt haben, wenn die Zeit gekommen ist für den richtigen Sound.
Ich war halt auch zu der Zeit so überdrücklich von Texten in Musik. Und dann gab es endlich mal eine Musik.
Genau, das wollte ich mir auch noch sagen. Erstens wurde nicht gelabert, das fand ich auch großartig. Und zweitens dachte ich mir so, wow, endlich mal der geile Sound, den ich damals schon auf meinem C64 immer gehört habe. Also es war irgendwie auch so diese Klangwelt des Computers, die mir da irgendwie doch sehr bekannt vorkam.
Ja, bei mir kam dazu, also ich war zu dieser Zeit auch noch ziemlich viel William Gibson und solche Bruce Stirling und solche Sachen gelesen, so Cyberpunk. Und es hat genau, also es war mein Soundtrack zum Lesen dieser Bücher.
Was hat da gepasst?
Na eben, dass eben keine Message drin war und halt dieses einerseits archaische Technik, also wenn du damals einen DX7 gesehen hast, den konntest du wegschmeißen, gib mir lieber eine 303 dafür. Ich will keinen digitalen Synthesizer mit 1000 Presets, sondern ich will schrauben können.
Yamaha DX7, sehr populäres Keyboard damals.
War zu der Zeit irgendwie das 9 plus Ultra. Wenn du irgendwo einen Act gesehen hast auf einer Bühne, statt immer, egal ob mit Stromanschluss dran oder nicht, immer DX7 auf der Bühne.
Spielt auch ohne Strom.
Und ja, also einerseits archaische Technik, also veraltete Technik, die du billig kaufen kannst, aber daraus eine Zukunft gebaut irgendwie. Und kein Text vor allem, keine Message mehr irgendwie. Nicht, dass mir einer sagt, du hast so und so zu funktionieren, ich hab das und das rausgefunden und so und so sollst du leben.
Liebe, Herzschmerzen.
Ich war dem ganzen so überdrissig und endlich mal Musik wurde stundenlang. Wenn da eine Stimme vorkam, dann war es einfach nur als Instrument. Ein Sample, das irgendwie wiederholt wurde und einfach den Rhythmus unterstützt hat. Aber nichts mehr, womit einer was erzählt. Das war für mich damals zungenvoll. Man war einfach irgendwie dem ganzen überdrissig. Gleichzeitig gab es ja auch damals diese ganzen Mandelbrot-Sachen oder sowas. Und ich hatte mir dann extra mal aus Amerika so...
Was machst du damit jetzt? Die Grafiken?
Die Grafiken, ja. Also diese Mandelbrot-Mengen oder diese Faktale. Diese ganzen Sachen, die sind ja zu der gleichen Zeit etwa auch gekommen. 88, 89, sowas. Ich hab mir dann gleich aus Amerika so, da gab es von irgendeiner Uni, gab es einen Film irgendwie mit diesen, also so ein VHS, über 30 Minuten irgendwie, wo so ein Faktal sich verändert. Hab ich mir aus Amerika gestellt und hab das zu der Musik laufen lassen.
Stimmt, das war so die Zeit, als die Computer gerade so schnell genug wurden, dass man sowas berechnen konnte.
Und das war halt irgendwie der Hammer. Das hab ich dann auch damals im UFO. Wurde sogar der Taz inseriert, irgendwie Acid zusammen mit Fraktalen, mit bewegten Fraktalen irgendwie. Ich hatte einen Abend nur mit Mathematikern, die nicht getanzt haben, aber es war trotzdem...
Die waren trotzdem fasziniert.
Jaja, die standen davor, die Musik hätte eigentlich aus sein können. Die wollten nur diese bewegten Fraktale sehen. Aber das hat alles zusammengepasst. Im Nachhinein haben sich so Sachen kulminiert. Hierzulande war zu der Zeit die Droge noch gar nicht so das Thema. Wir waren damals noch völlig clean alle. Wenn man sich da im UFO getroffen hat, das war wirklich nur diese Faszination über die Musik. Bei mir noch diese neue Technik, Cyberpunk und so weiter. Da hat jeder seinen eigenen Kosmos rausgebaut. Das war die richtige Kombination zur richtigen Zeit, wo jeder auch seinen eigenen Kosmos bauen konnte. Die Eiden kamen mehr von der Disko. Ich kannte viele, die gekommen sind. Die waren vorher im Metropol bei einem Westbim, der dann High Energy gespielt hat, was auch ein Vorbote von Techno war. Sehr schnelle, härtere Disko-Musik. Dann kamen welche aus dem Punk. Es gab welche, die kamen aus der Grufti-Ecke, die vorher auch elektronischen Grufti-Kram gehört haben. Das hat alles k culminiert in so ein Ding, zu sagen, hier ist ein Nullpunkt, von wo aus wir eine neue Zukunft schaffen. Sehr idealistisch damals gedacht.
Die Techno-Wolke, die ich vorhin angesprochen habe. Was auch die Kraft hatte, alle Disziplinen zu vereinigen. So wie auch die Computer. Wenn man damals mit Computern gearbeitet hat, so ist es ja auch heute noch, aber damals war das noch mal ein viel größeres Privileg. Man konnte eigentlich in jeder Branche irgendwie gebraucht werden. Man könnte überall andocken. Jeder fand das interessant. Jeder hatte irgendwie einen Nutzen davon. Man konnte extrem disziplinübergreifend aktiv werden. Eine ähnliche Attraktivität in der anderen Richtung hat hier auch die Musik gespielt, denke ich. Dass jeder da so einen Ort gefunden hat, wo er sich aufs Neue verwirklichen kann und seine bisher gemachten Erfahrungen und seinen Genre da mit einbringt.
Der Computer wurde ja auch immer wichtiger. Von daher wurde auch elektronische Musik natürlich auch ein Zeichen der Zeit. Die Ataris fingen gerade an, irgendwie populär zu werden. Wann auch auf Cubase fingen an, irgendwie populär zu werden.
Also die Atari ST-Serie, die ersten Homecomputers mit eingebauten Niede-Schnittstellen. Was ganz wichtig war, genau. Nicht nur für die Musiker, sondern auch für die Plattformen, die jetzt sonst nicht geschafft sich zu halten. Aber das war ein genialer Schachzug seiner Zeit. Das zu sehen, ja stimmt. Da kam dann nämlich auch die erste Generation von Sequencer-Software hoch. Cubase, hast du schon gesagt, war damals ganz groß und auch so einige andere, die auch heute ja noch eine große Bedeutung haben. Interessant, das ist wirklich ein interessanter Punkt. Wenn man sich nämlich heute mal den Markt anschaut für Musiksoftware, Hardware weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau, aber insbesondere diese Sequencer-Geschichten und so weiter, das ist eine ganz besondere Nummer. Da kommt einfach fast alles aus Deutschland. Also nicht nur so, aber alle großen Pakete, was weiß ich hier, Logic, Cubase, gibt es bestimmt noch ein paar andere Beispiele. Ableton, genau, hier auch aus Berlin. Wo Deutschland ansonsten in so vielen Bereichen softwaretechnisch eigentlich komplett verloren hat, wo immer die großen Trends aus den USA kamen und hier und da mal die Ausnahme, die die Regel bestätigt hat, war das bei dem Audio ganz anders. Warum? Hast du da eine Erklärung dafür?
Nein, eine wirklich Erklärung nicht, aber...
Also überhaupt, warum bitte ist denn diese Techno? Ich meine, wir hatten ja vorhin so dieses kommt aus den USA und man kann ja feststellen, in den USA hat diese ganze Techno überhaupt nicht gegriffen. Also es gab zwar diesen Einfluss mit Haus und Partykultur und was weiß ich und was da so rübergespabbt ist. Dann gab es so ein bisschen diese Geschmacksverstärker, die Briten, die dann immer gleich alles so unglaublich exzessiv machen, die quasi den Rave geboren haben, wahrscheinlich auch noch so den modernen Drogenmissbrauch des auslaufenden 20. Jahrhunderts. So und das Ganze schwapperte dann aber wiederum nach Deutschland irgendwie weiter. Also man kann schon sagen, da passierte erstmal was in Britannien, dann so in Mitteleuropa, also gar nicht mehr nur auf Deutschland reduzieren. Aber dann war es auf einmal ein deutsches Ding. Ein deutsches Ding und dann natürlich auch nochmal ein besonderes, natürlich auch Berlin. Das kam natürlich dann auch zusammen mit dem Mauerfall und dieser eisigartigen Situation, dass es dann hier offene Locations ohne Ende gab. Und dann machte es ja einfach nur noch Peng. Love Parade startete, dann diese ganzen Clubs, die damals ja auch sofort weltweite Bedeutung gehabt haben, das Paar ist ja schon erwähnt, hier Tresor, quasi der Nachfolger von dem UFO, wenn ich es richtig sehe.
Ganz wichtig waren auch diese Technozid-Raves, die Wolle XDP damals gemacht hat. Weil das waren dann die ersten Raves auf deutschem Boden. Also das war 90, 91 hatten wir hier die ersten Raves gemacht. Wir hatten angefangen mit 450 Leuten, beim ersten im Haus der jungen Talente damals in der Klosterstraße.
Heute das Polyvillen, ja.
Und das hatte sich von Mal zu Mal, wir hatten das am Anfang, glaube ich, einmal im Monat gemacht oder noch selten, alle sechs Wochen oder so. Und es war jemals eine Potenzierung von 100 Prozent. Angefangen mit 450 Leuten. Das nächste Mal waren es schon 1000, beim nächsten Mal schon 1500 oder 2000. Das Ding ist von Mal zu Mal mehr explodiert. Das war der Hammer. Da hast du auch schon gesehen, alter, hier passiert gerade irgendwas, war auch nach Mauerfall irgendwie. Da hast du gemerkt, wenn du das vorher erlebt hast, mit 150 Leuten in einem Kellerloch, mit einer scheiß PA, irgendwo gerade mal ein Mixer steht, der vielleicht noch nicht mal einen Crossfeder damals hatte, sondern auch irgendwo ausgeliehen war und plötzlich explodiert das Ding auf. Irgendwie innerhalb von Monaten auf 2.000, 3.000 Leute. Wo kommen die alle her? Ende 88 bis Mitte 90 war das passiert eigentlich. Von 150 auf über 2.000.
Das heißt aber noch so vor dem Mauerfall. Der Mauerfall kam sozusagen genau zum richtigen Zeitpunkt. So Partiebedarf, es kommen immer mehr Leute, scheiße wir brauchen mehr Platz. Also der Mauerfall hatte nichts mit Günter Schabowski zu tun. Das war einfach das Techno-Kartell Westberlins, die gesagt haben, wir brauchen mehr Platz.
Also der Boom kam ja dann auch erst durch diesen Mauerfall. Was ja auch logisch war. Für mich war es, oder ist es im Nachhinein logisch, also in dem Moment, wo man drin gesteckt hat, hat man gar nicht über sowas nachgedacht. Aber als diese Mauer dann fiel, brauchte das Ganze auch einen Soundtrack. Jeder Soundtrack, der vorher schon existiert hatte, war entweder durch Osten oder durch Westen belegt. Rock war durch Westen belegt, dieser ganze Ostrock hätte dich zum Westen gepackt. Und da war eine Generation, die auf was Neues wartete. Die Mauer bricht zusammen, es ist Elektronik da. Plötzlich können die sich da drüben auch Computer kaufen. Es liegt natürlich als elektronische, es ist noch überhaupt nicht geformt.
Du meinst, die Generation hat sich ihre Hymne und ihre Musik der Zeit einfach gewählt?
In dem Moment ist es einfach so passiert. Es war für beide Seiten ein weißes Blatt. Wir 150 Leute, die da im Westen dazu schon ein Jahr getanzt haben, es war in dem Moment scheißegal. Es ist ein unbeschriebenes Blatt gewesen. Jeder konnte es formen. Es war ja noch völlig undefiniert. Es gab ja noch nicht mal richtig das Wort Techno. Das kam erst ab 1991 oder so. Da kam das erste, als Techno definiert wurde. Ich hab damals noch offen in meine Flyette drunter geschrieben, ein Mix 2 aus Asset House, Industriel und Industriel Hip Hop. Weil es einfach noch nicht dieses Wort gab. Ich wollte halt alles irgendwie zusammenbringen.
Was spielt ihr denn eigentlich?
Und erst ab 1991 gab es dann halt irgendwie so richtig dieses Wort Techno. Es gab das Wort Techno vorher schon, aber das wollten wir nicht benutzen, weil das in Frankfurt eher in diese Front 2 for 2 Rechnung ging.
Das war dann auch glaube ich immer mehr so Techno mit Doppel-K.
Nein, das kam erst dann bei Technozid, weil das mit Doppel-K geschrieben wurde. Das war halt die extrem harte Variante. Und so mehr K, umso härter die Musik war dann damals die Definition.
Was gibt es da noch zu erwähnen? Dann gab es natürlich das E-Werk direkt in die Ecke.
Erst mal Planet. Das wurde später zum E-Werk.
Planet wurde zum E-Werk?
Ja, die Leute, die das Planet gemacht hatten, das war ja früher auch in der Köpenicker Straße am Ufer, mussten die Location irgendwann aufgeben. Und dann gab es dieses E-Werk gegenüber vom Finanzministerium. Da war vorher schon mal eine Party auf dem Dach gewesen. Da hat sich schon jeder gedacht, haben wir Location.
Also Finanzministerium ist da heute drin?
Damals, was war da drin? Ich weiß gar nicht. Also zu der Zeit stand es halt da, weil irgendwas ECD-mäßiges vorher drin war. Ursprünglich war es das Lufthartministerium von Nazis, glaube ich. Und ja, also das... da war schon mal auf dem Dach irgendwann eine Party gewesen. 90 oder so. Und dann mussten die das 92 oder 93 mussten sie den Planet aufgeben. Da war ja dann die Strahlauer weitergewandelt und sind dann erst sozusagen gegenüber vom Tresor auch. Der Tresor war ja schon seit Anfang an in der... also es war damals auch so eine schöne gegenseitige...
Also muss man dazu sagen, der Tresor hieß Tresor, weil er im ehemaligen Tresorraum des Wertheim-Kaufhauses, was dort an der Stelle stand, aber im Krieg zerstört wurde, sich eingenistelt hat. Ich erinnere mich noch, ich war da mehrere Male und dann... also das war wirklich... das muss auch... bei mir hat das gewirkt. Das muss bei vielen Leuten gewirkt haben. Diese Atmosphäre, die man hatte, wenn man da rein kam. Ich meine erst mal einfach dieses zerstörte Ost-Berlin, dieses Grau, diese vollständige Abwesenheit jeglicher moderner Infrastruktur. Alles war irgendwie heruntergekommen und rostig und dreckig und baufällig und was nicht alles. Dann dieser Tresorraum, der an sich nochmal so ein Relikt aus dem Krieg war und noch mit diesen ganzen verrosteten Tresorgittern und so weiter. Und dann halt wirklich so ein Keller, komplett hermetisch abgeregelt, irgendwie wummernde Techno-Bässe. Also mit Beton umgeben und dann einfach nur Strobo und Nebel umgeben und das war's. Das war natürlich auch extrem minimalistisch, in jeder Hinsicht. Die Musik war minimalistisch, die Umgebung war irgendwie minimalistisch, die ganze Dekoration. Nur die Stimmung war definitiv nicht minimalistisch. Das stimmt. Ein unglaublicher Exzess, der sich da abgespielt hat.
Ich war ja der erste Resident da unten. Ich hab das Ding auch schon gesehen gehabt, bevor das als Club dann aufgemacht wurde. Ich wurde dann gefragt, was hältst du davon? Ich war erst mal, wow, so was gibt's? Boah, das als Club, Hammer! Man hat sich das angeguckt, aber ich hätte nie gedacht, dass das dann so abging. Das war schon bei dem ersten Mal, als wir da unten waren, das war einfach, du bist in eine andere Welt da unten gegangen. Du warst einfach mit dem, was über der Erde war, abgeschlossen eigentlich. Es gab nur noch diesen Raum und das Abgehen. Und da haben Leute irgendwie Techniken gefunden zum Abgehen. Das war ja damals alles noch in Berlin unter Besatzungszone. Und wir hatten natürlich auch eine Menge Engländer, die irgendwie rausgekriegt haben, dass es jetzt in Berlin auch so was gibt wie bei Ihnen in England. Das waren halt vorher Rewe. Dann wurden sie irgendwie zur Armee verfrachtet und wollten aber am Wochenende auch feiern gehen.
Ach ja, die britischen Soldaten. Das ist ja auch noch mal so ein Thema.
Und die sind ja mal abgegangen. Also die hatten dann auch diese Drogen halt mitgebracht nach Berlin. Wir waren damals doch...
Das waren dann auch die mit den Leutstäbchen und den weißen Handschuhen und so?
Ja, ja, doch. Ja, genau. Weiße Handschuhe. Das haben die alles hier eingebracht und dann halt auch die Exe-Season.
Ich habe mich immer gefragt, was machen die da?
Die sehen so komisch aus und die Augen so dick und sowas irgendwie. Und dann war da irgendwie, wir hatten damals im Tresor so ein von Bose, so ein Basssystem, das war so eine Röhre an der Decke. Und dann war da noch so ein alter Spind in der Ecke gestanden und ab und zu habe ich da so einen Engländer drinnen gesehen, stehend in dem Spind. Irgendwie, was macht der da? Habe ich da selber mal reingestellt und diese Basswelle ist halt genau auf diesen Spind drauf. Und wenn die diese REs geklingt haben, dann in diesem Ding drehen. Also ich glaube, das ist ein Wirkungsverstärker hoch zehn gewesen.
Oh ja, also da gab es echt eine Menge Opfer.
Naja, auf jeden Fall. Aber es hat halt damals auch zur Musik dazugehört. Ich habe dann auch irgendwann die erste Ehe geklingt. Und dann halt, ach, so funktioniert das. Und das war halt irgendwie, du hast ja auch verstanden, warum die anderen Leute plötzlich so abgehen irgendwie. Also, ah, okay, deswegen gehen die hier so ab. Deswegen, ich bin morgens um sechs schlapp und die wollen immer noch weitermachen und so weiter. Also, das muss man auch immer irgendwie so im Kontext miteinander sehen. Das hat natürlich auch schon dann später eine Menge ausgemacht, ne? Also, auch dieses drei Tage Wacht, das dann irgendwann da draus wurde und so weiter. After-Our-Kultur ist auch ein ganz wichtiger Teil von Techno.
Was hat das bezeichnet?
Eine Drei Tage Wacht bedeutet einfach, du gehst Freitags losfeiern und kommst irgendwann Montags wieder nach Hause.
Mir war nicht so bewusst, dass das so ein stehender Begriff war. Ich hab eine Erinnerung, dass die Grünen das jetzt gerade für ihren Wahlkampfendsport als Titel gehabt haben.
Nee, da gab es auch mal ein...
Jetzt weiß ich, wie sie das gemerkt haben.
Ja, drei Tage Wacht. Das war definitiv auch so ein Ding. Diese Partywochenenden war halt nicht so, dass man am Wochenende auf eine Party geht, sondern man ging halt das ganze Wochenende auf eine Party. Das ganze Wochenende war eigentlich eine Party. Und man reite, das gibt es sicherlich auch heute noch, aber das war dann schon auch so ein Phänomen und auch so ein unglaublicher Trend, dass man eigentlich von Club zu Club zog.
Und danach ging es dann auch privat weiter.
Ja, genau, dass die Clubs auch sich immer irgendwie mit ihren Öffnungszeiten eigentlich so gegenseitig die Hand gegeben haben, dass man halt immer wieder weiterziehen konnte. Wie war denn so damals eigentlich die Akzeptanz der Stadt oder der etablierten Gesellschaft gegenüber diesem Techno- und diesem Techno-Club-Phänomen? Ich meine, am Anfang gab es ja noch lange Zeit, denke ich mal, war man weitgehend unbehelligt, weil der Staat einfach damit zu tun hatte, sich überhaupt erst mal selbst zu organisieren und zu finden. Gerade im Osten, keiner wusste, wem irgendwas gehört oder wer wo über welche Macht drüber verfügt. Die DDR war am Zerbröseln. Einheit gab es erst 90 und dann hat es auch nochmal ein paar Jahre gedauert, bis man irgendwie wusste, wo oben und unten war.
Wie vogelfrei war denn das? Das war sehr vogelfrei. Also so eine Neunzigerstresse aufmacht und blindet aufmacht und so. Da war ja alles möglich. Also es wusste ja keiner, was darf man, was darf man nicht irgendwie. Wir haben damals Locations aufgebrochen, im Nebenschrankland die Polizei, die hat sich halt gedacht, ich guck da lieber nicht hin, ich weiß ja nicht, was ich darf und so weiter. Du konntest einfach Dinge aufbrechen und gucken, oh, was mach ich jetzt da draus? Och, eignet sich für eine Bar, machen wir eine Bar draus. Der nächste ist halt aufgebrochen, oh, cool, geiler Laden, hier verkaufe ich meine Klamotten und so weiter. Also es war damals einfach ein völlig anarchischer Zustand. Aber man wünscht sich heute manchmal solche Zustände zurück, wenn du siehst, wie verkrustet das ist und was für Auflagen und sowas alles erfüllen muss. Wenn du siehst, was damals an Netzwerken entstanden ist, die bis heute funktionieren, also damals in diesem anarchischen Zustand, dann wünscht man sich schon manchmal, dass diese ganzen Regulierungsdinger da mal ein bisschen zurückgenommen werden, damit sowas halt mal wieder möglich ist, damit Leute sich endlich mal wieder austoben können. Gut, hier in Berlin sind wir dann noch in einer ganz guten Situation, aber wenn ich dadurch Westdeutschland ture oder sowas sehe, okay, die müssen ja schon seit 30 Jahren im gleichen Club feiern, weil die Stadt einfach nichts anderes zulässt, obwohl da irgendwie eine Halle frei steht und sich alle drum bemühen, kann man da was tun, machen, aber wird halt nicht gerne gesehen. Also es war ja von Anfang an bei Techno dieses Drogending irgendwie, dass jemand, der in Techno drin war, es gar nicht so schlimm empfunden hat, außer die Paar Opfer, die halt irgendwie nicht das Ende gefunden haben, sondern immer noch mehr eingeklingt haben, was dann aber auch nichts gegen das ist, was du dann zum Beispiel gesehen hast, wenn du auf Weinfeste fährst, in Bayern auf das Torballfest, wie die Leute da kurz in der Ecke liegen, sowas habe ich jetzt bei Techno nicht so oft gesehen. Also ich fand diesen Drogenaspekt irgendwie immer mit Vorsicht zu genießen, aber auch gleichzeitig muss man die Leuten das Recht zugestehen und diese staatliche so, hey, wenn so was passiert gleich, ich habe dann Razzien erlebt irgendwie, die waren echt nicht schön wohl. Also die Leute einfach ein Auto nach einem anderen abgefangen wurden und die Leute auch so behandelt wurden wie Verbrecher, wo ich dann auch mal zu einem Polizist gesagt habe, sie können mich gerne so behandeln, wenn sie irgendwas mit mir feststellen, aber solange sie bei mir nichts festgestellt haben, behandeln sie mich bitte wie denjenigen, der sie bezahlt. Also ich fand es einfach eine Frechheit, Leute von vornherein irgendwie wie Kriminelle zu behandeln, bloß weil sie mal drauf waren oder noch nicht mal drauf waren, weil sie nur vermutet wurden, dass sie drauf waren.
Und dann hat sich das aber irgendwann wieder geändert?
Nee, das hat sich natürlich nicht, das wurde immer schlimmer eigentlich. Aber man wusste damit halt umzugehen.
Diese Vogelfreiheit hat sich halt irgendwann geändert.
Ach so, die hat sich dann ab 1993 gelegt. 1993 hast du gemerkt, okay, jetzt kommt wieder Struktur rein. Da hatte ich einen Club in Mitte, da ist ehemals das Ahrhorn Blatt Exit, hieß es.
Ein Gebäude, das heute nicht mehr gibt?
Ja, leider. Da fand ich es echt schade drumherum. Da steht ja so ein blödes New Hotel.
Da war auch echt ein Club drin?
Wir hatten da Freitags und Sonntags auf. Der Sonntag war halt irgendwie, wir hatten früher Wahlfisch als After Hour. Die After Hour-Kultur, die fand ich bei Techno auch sehr wichtig, weil da ist diese ganze Kommunikation auch passiert. Du warst in den Clubs tanzen gewesen und danach, so ab Sonntag mittags, eins, manche morgens schon um 7, manche sind halt direkt von den Clubs weiter dahin gelaufen, völlig durch. Andere sind halt aufgestanden, weil sie gesagt haben, Freitags, Samstag brauche ich erstmal von meiner Arbeit runterzukommen, Sonntag gehe ich zur After Hour. Und das war halt dann irgendwie so diese Mischung aus völlig Truffen und völlig Nüchternen, die sich aber sehr gut miteinander verstanden haben, genauso wie Ost und West irgendwie da auch vertreten waren und wo in anderen Gesellschaftsschichten immer noch so die Rede davon war, irgendwie so, der ist aus dem Osten, die sind ganz anders als wir, da war das bei uns nie ein Thema, das war so scheißegal, wo einer herkam.
Stimmt, da gab es kein Ost-West-Ding, oder? Überhaupt nicht.
Nee, gab es nicht. Auch ob einer Truff war oder nicht Truff war, das war so scheißegal, du bist halt irgendwie auf das gleiche Ding gegangen und warst in deine eigene Welt irgendwie mit Truffen, Ossis, Wessis, Klinen irgendwie und das hat alles super miteinander funktioniert. Und das hat sich ja auch zum Glück in großen Teilen bis heute gehalten. Also wenn du jetzt heute so bar 25 gehst oder sowas, das ist das gleiche Phänomen. Da siehst du, Leute sind schon seit drei Tagen dabei und es gibt Leute, die da sonntagabend erst hingehen. Und da passiert halt die Kommunikation, weil das Schöne ist ja, dass in der Musik keine Texte vorkommen. Du bist also sprachlich jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit belastet, sondern du hast dann wirklich die Zeit auch an Sonntagabend irgendwie dich mit Leuten zu unterhalten, ohne dass du jetzt irgendwie drei Tage Messages mit dem Messag zugewonnen wurdest.
Ja, der Chill-Out als Party-Konzept, das ist definitiv auch etwas. Also Chill-Out auch so als bewusstes Abkühlen nach dem heißen Tanz so und was dann extrem, ja, habe ich auch mal als extrem kommunikationsfördernd erlebt.
Das Leid heute aus den meisten Clubs verschwunden, weil ich ein bisschen traurig finde so.
Das war eigentlich Standard, es gab immer die Party-Räume, dann gab es die Chill-Out-Räume, wo man sich irgendwie hinsetzen konnte, was weiß ich, im Idealfall noch mal tratzen und decken, wo man auch mal...
Wo dann auch ein anderer DJ wirklich eine Ambient- Musik gespielt hat, Orb und solche Sachen, fand ich immer sehr... Also fand ich früher... Na ja, das war auch eine Bereicherung. Heute ist dann halt mit der Zeit dazu verschwunden, dass der eine Raum Techno unter anderem hausspielt. Es wurde halt in beiden Räumen getanzt.
Kranvier und Western sozusagen.
Aber leider hat sich dieser Chill-Out nicht so durchgesetzt. Er ist mit der Zeit verschwunden. Leider.
Dabei war gerade diese Ambient-Musik auch sehr experimentell. Neben Berlin gab es ja auch noch ein paar andere Epizentren. Ich denke, da kann man vor allem Frankfurt und Hamburg nennen. Auch Köln damals. In allen Städten ging was. Köln auch. Das kann ich nicht so bewerten. Frankfurt hat ja auch ein paar berühmte Clubs hervorgebracht. Das ist das Omen, Sven Feet, Dorian Gray zu der Zeit auch. Am Flughafen war das. Hamburg hat dann wiederum diese speziellen Hafenkomponente gehabt, dass dort diese ganzen verträumten Hippies in der Regel gestrandet sind, die frisch aus Indien zurückkamen, wo sie in Goa diesen ganzen Techno-Export betrieben haben. Das heißt, dort fanden dann diese legendären Strandpartys statt, die jetzt heute so in der Form auch nicht mehr stattfinden, weil es den Inneren ein Dorn im Auge ist, haben dann aber sozusagen dort überwintert und sind dann im Sommer wieder zurückgekommen und haben dann aber natürlich dieses Partymodell dann in die Hamburger Region getragen, wo es großartige Open-Air-Veranstaltungen gab, während man in Berlin eigentlich immer so mit der Bierflasche im Keller stand. So hab ich das immer gesehen, bisschen zynisch die Formulierung. Aber Open-Air-Partys kamen dann sehr viel später eigentlich erst in Mode und da hat eigentlich auch nie so wirklich jetzt den Kern getroffen, während man sich in Hamburg eigentlich weniger in den Clubs abfeiert. Es gab so ein paar, aber...
Das gab's Unit damals?
Das gab's Unit vor allem. Im Tunnel? Im Tunnel, es gab natürlich überhaupt die ganze Reeperbahn, klar. Hatte natürlich auch Techno im Angebot und da war dann irgendwie auch Chillout und After-Or, das gab sich alles in die Hand. Aber die Haupt-Events waren eigentlich immer die Open-Air-Partys, zumindest für diese besondere Sektion. Es gab ja dann neben dem, was wir jetzt bisher an Musikstilen besprochen haben, dann eben auch noch diesen spezifischen Trans, nicht wahr? Trans, diese Goa-Music und so weiter.
Das fand ich immer ganz schrecklich.
Das fand man sich ganz schrecklich, aber war so ein bisschen diese Blumen-Hippiewelt. Aber war dann auf jeden Fall auch immer sehr gemütlich und draußen und naturverbunden und so. Und da war dann auch für jeden was zu finden.
Heute hast du ja auch immer noch die Diffusion zum Beispiel, die ist ja auch noch ein Spätprodukt davon eigentlich.
Gerade die Diffusion ist nämlich insofern bemerkenswert, weil sie ja aus Hamburg kamen. Also die Leute kamen aus Hamburg. Weiß ich noch, war auf der ersten Fusion, also noch Fusion Sound, ne, wie hieß das nochmal? Weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht. Auf jeden Fall, das war mal irgendwie so ein kleiner Event beim Planten und Blomen sozusagen mitten in Hamburg und irgendwie draußen. Später zog das dann irgendwie dann an dieses Gelände da in der Müritz. Und das ist ja mittlerweile, glaube ich, einer der größten Veranstaltungen überhaupt in dem Bereich.
Also mit Le Chabon und Sonne, Mond, Sterne die drei größten.
Und eine, die auch sich immer noch extrem treu geblieben ist. War jetzt letzten zwei, drei Jahre nicht mehr da, aber definitiv nicht durch den Kommerz zerstört.
Nee, die haben sich auch sehr geöffnet. Also immer mehr Floors, immer mehr Artists da. Also ist schon ein Riesending geworden. Mir ist es zum Beispiel schon zu groß. Ich pack das nicht. Also solche Mendenmengen.
Wir sind ja auch schon alt.
Nee, also mir ist es dann echt zu viel. Also ich brauch dann immer mein Rückzugsgebiet, weil so viel Verpeiltheit und Doofheit irgendwie auf meinem Haufen ist. Ist dann doch schon sehr anstrengend.
Ja, also der Cyberpunk in seinen verschiedensten Ausprägungen, auch die Computerleute hatten ja damals eine besondere Verbindung zu diesem ganzen Techno-Ding. Das war so meine Wahrnehmung, also schon im Tresor standen Anfang der 90er Jahre schon Chat-Terminals. Ich weiß noch, da gab es diesen Club-Chat, der da irgendwie aufgemacht wurde. So ein Terminal in jedem Club in Berlin eigentlich am Ende, wo man dann halt so einen Chat-Rom hatte und sich irgendwie unterhalten konnte. Also die ganzen Nerds drängten auch in diese Szene rein und versuchten, ihr Ding zu bringen als VJs. Wie hast du das wahrgenommen?
Na du hast halt schon gemerkt, da kamen jetzt Leute mit ihren Computern an irgendwie und haben dann irgendwie so Grafik miteinander verbunden. Ich war da nie so Teil davon irgendwie. Ich hab das immer nur bewundert irgendwie. Die haben halt irgendwie irgendwelche Files aus dem Internet dann später geholt und die dann miteinander überblendet. Peter Rubin war ja da so der erste, der das dann damals auf der Medie gemacht hatte irgendwie und den fand ich allerdings jetzt von der Bildauswahl nie so besonders gelungen, sondern da gab's einige, die haben dann wirklich Bilder zu dieser Musik geschaffen im Club. Das fand ich schon super. Ich glaube, die haben auch mit Ataris gearbeitet, weil sie halt auch diese Mini-Schnittstellen für den Mixer brauchten, für die Kontrolle oder so. Oder auch diese ganze Trecker-Szene damals, die hat ja auch schon...
Amiga war auch sehr stark. Amiga gerade auf dem Trecker, also die Trecker gerade auf dem Amiga, aber Amiga war natürlich auch grafisch ganz vorn. Stimmt.
Und die Trecker hatten ja auch schon damals irgendwie so, also zum Beispiel DJ Hard Sequencer damals. Aus Dresden? Aus Dresden, heute Hardy Hard. Der hat ja damals auch mit Trecker-Sachen angefangen. Die ersten Sachen, die er auf Low Spirit rausgebracht hat, das waren eigentlich Sachen, die auf dem Trecker entstanden sind. Auf Amiga, glaube ich.
Die Trecker waren ja im Prinzip so... Ich versuch das gerade mal so software-technisch einzuordnen. Die Trecker waren ja im Prinzip auch so minimalistische Sequencer-Programme, kann man sagen. Die aber von vornherein so gedacht waren, dass sie eben den Sound auf dem Computer erzeugen. Während ja die ersten Sequencer-Programme, Cubase und so weiter, die wir angesprochen haben, ja immer dafür da waren, Keyboards einzubinden, externen Synthesizer dann eben über MIDI miteinander zu verbinden, weil der Rechner kaum zu mehr in der Lage war, eigentlich das zu machen. Während die Trecker sehr minimalistisch angefangen haben mit sehr kleinen Sound-Schnipseln, die jetzt so ein gestandener Musiker wahrscheinlich gar nicht als Musik ernst genommen hätte, aber wer halt mit dem C64 groß geworden ist und den drei Kanälen, die der Synthesizer dort erzeugt hat, der war nicht anspruchsvoll. Und so kam das dann eben langsam zueinander. Ja, also auch hier merkt man wieder diese Gesamtkultur. Das ist ja auch eigentlich das, warum ich jetzt hier der Meinung war, dass Techno hier bei CRE mal ein Thema sein sollte, weil es ja mehr ist als nur jetzt so ein Musikgenre. Es ist etwas extrem Umfangreiches geworden, was teilweise aus Musik besteht, teilweise aus einer Partykultur besteht, was gesellschaftlich eine extrem große Bedeutung gehabt hat, wie wir das eben gerade schon gesehen haben. Dieses Ost-West spielt keine Rolle mehr. Es war irgendwie auch die Musik der Zeit, es war die Symphonie der Zeit. Und dazu war es ja extrem neophil, weil es einfach auch alles aufgenommen hat. Alle aktuelle Entwicklungen in der Software, in der Hardware, Computertechnik generell.
Genau, die ganze Netzwerkgedanke. Also damals hat man sich halt noch mit Fax irgendwie am Anfang irgendwie verständigt. Und als dann so 94, 95 Internet kamen, war auch damals Frontpage oder wie die ganzen Sachen damals hießen, die hatten sofort Internet.
Die hatten alle Webseiten, die hatten alle E-Mail.
Und wurde dann plötzlich mit E-Mails kommuniziert. Viel schneller irgendwie. Das wurde also da sehr schnell aufgenommen.
Stimmt, das war eigentlich relativ schnell normal.
Auch die Planet-Leute hatten dann auch gleich irgendwie so Internetseite, ich weiß nicht mehr, planet.com oder so was, glaube ich, damals. Die dann auch irgendwie, also die Kommunikation war auf einmal also ums Zehnfache beschleunigt worden irgendwie innerhalb dieser Macher-Szene. Als ich dann 95 Internet gekriegt habe, habe ich gedacht, ich bin bestimmt einer der Letzten irgendwie. Hab aber gemerkt, das ist wirklich halt nur diese Macher-Szene. Also das Publikum selber war dann noch nicht so selber Technik-Afführen gewesen. Aber da hast du auch schon gesehen, Techno, da steckt nicht nur irgendwie Technik in dem Namen drin, sondern auch so dieses Aufnehmen von neuer Technik, sei es in Produktion, sei es in Kommunikation oder so was, das war immer sofort da gewesen. Kaum, was du was mitkriegt, war es auch schon da.
Macher-Szene, sagst du. Was waren denn das so für Leute, die du so begegnet bist da?
Na das war sehr unterschiedlich. Also hier in Berlin hatten wir halt bis heute den Vorteil, dass die Macher der Szene, also wenn jemand einen Club macht, kommt er meistens irgendwie aus der Szene selber. Während ich in anderen Städten halt so erlebt hatte, dass da war der Disco, die haben gesehen, okay, die Kids wollen Techno, also mache ich Freitag oder Samstag, mache ich halt den Abend Techno. Und das Hasse halt, dann hing da noch die Vert T-Shirts-Contest-Poster und am nächsten Tag hing dann das Smiley da irgendwie. Und das war halt, es hat funktioniert, weil du hast dann, diese Clubbetreiber haben dann manchmal auch komplett umgeschwenkt, weil sie halt gemerkt haben irgendwie, ey, also ist super und kann ich mich nicht nur arrangieren, sondern die haben sich dann wirklich auch reingetan. Aber du hast halt gemerkt, die kommen nicht wirklich aus der Sache, sondern schwenken dann um.
Hat funktioniert?
Ja, viele sind dann auch umgeschwenkt und haben das halt kapiert und sind dann auch wirklich, also du würdest wirklich sagen können, das sind dann Feierschweine geworden.
Rehwer?
Ja, sind richtige Rehwer geworden. Aber es kam halt immer aus einem anderen Kontext. Während in Berlin war es halt so, das sind Leute, die haben vorher an der Bar gearbeitet oder in einem ganz anderen Club irgendwie, haben dann sich zusammengeschlossen zu irgendeinem Kombinat irgendwie, vier, fünf Leute und die haben dann gesagt, okay, wir machen jetzt einen Club. Und das ist halt bis heute so. Also fast alle Clubs, die ich kenne irgendwie, da ist es immer noch so, dass die Leute von irgendwo kommen und dann halt gesagt haben, okay, jetzt machen wir selber, wir haben hier einen Location, lass uns das Ding groß machen.
Im Internet war es ja auch damals sehr ähnlich zu dieser Situation in Berlin. Es gab keine Kontrolle, keiner hat das irgendwie wahrgenommen. Man konnte irgendwie machen, was man will. Und es haben sich irgendwie innerhalb kürzester Zeit neue Netzwerke herausgebildet. Das hat ja eigentlich im Internet auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise genauso stattgefunden. Auch da war man noch nicht so auf dem gesellschaftlichen Radar. In gut 95 fing man an, darüber zu reden. Aber so vor, naja, 98, 99, denke ich mal, ist das wirklich noch nicht so richtig in der Gesellschaft angekommen. Man kann viel darüber diskutieren, ob das überhaupt schon in der Gesellschaft angekommen ist. Aber ich denke, da sind schon große Fortschritte erzielt worden.
Da fielen auch viele Autodidakten halt dabei auf beiden Seiten.
Aber für dich ist das Internet ja auch nicht ganz unwichtig.
Nee.
Du warst ja auch früher dabei. Ich kann mich noch mal erinnern, wir haben uns irgendwann mal unterhalten. Wo haben wir denn das eigentlich getan? Haben wir da irgendwie E-Mail geschrieben? Ich weiß nicht. Du hast auch, erinnere ich mich, sehr früh angefangen, als Napstar aufkam, deine Musik auch irgendwie online zu verbreiten. War das nicht so?
Ja, das habe ich mit den Mixen gemacht. Ich habe dann schon 1998, 1999 eine eigene Webseite aufgebaut, wo ich dann meinen Mix immer da drüber rausgehauen habe. Meinst du das? Also meine eigenen Tracks durfte ich damals gar nicht, weil da war ich noch bei einem Meter unter Vertrag. Die hätte ich nicht raushauen dürfen, so einfach. Aber es war damals auch noch ein sehr graues Feld, was man da darf und was man nicht darf.
Also du hast nur Mixe verbreitet?
Ich habe Mixe verbreitet zu der Zeit. Ich fand das den adäquatesten Weg, die in die Öffentlichkeit zu bringen. Anstatt 1000 CDs zu brennen und hier hast du einfach zu sagen, hier ist noch eine Webseite und du kannst ja runterziehen.
Und was hat das bewirkt?
Bewirkt hat es eine Menge Kommunikation. Also ich hatte zu der Zeit ja eigentlich so, also für einige Leute einen komischen Stand. Ich hatte ja Techno irgendwo verlassen zu der Zeit, weil ich ab 96 ziemlich angeödet von der Sache war, weil ich halt immer noch mit 909 und 303 irgendwie rumgezwirbelt wurde, während nebendran Drum & Bass halt mit einem Sampler Sachen angestellt hat, wo ich gedacht hatte, das ist genau das Ding, weswegen ich damals Techno eigentlich geil fand, weil halt völlig neue Soundkosmen aufgestoßen wurden und hab dann halt so Breakbeat-Sachen gemacht und hab die dann eigentlich über das Internet so ab 98, 99 irgendwie verbreitet. Also seit 96 eigentlich auch in Internetforen, 96, 97 oder Abfahrer.gr gab's damals schon als, weiß ich mal, zum Mählingenliste oder IRC-Channel oder so.
Abfahrer.gr Abfahrer.gr Klingt nach Mailbox-Netzen.
Ja, so irgendwas. Aber das war keine Mailbox mehr, das war irgendwie die IRC-Channel oder sowas, wo sich so die ersten Technos so ausgetauscht hatten. Und da hat man halt so die ersten Diskussionen gehabt. Und dann gab's auch bald die ersten Foren. Und da hab ich dann halt so irgendwie versucht, irgendwie so dieses, mich zu erklären, warum ich Techno langweilig fand. Irgendwie. Das war so meine erste Internetaktion.
Abfahrradgeher gibt's noch.
Gibt's noch, immer noch.
Das deutsche Echo über Techno, Haus und Rev im Fido-Netz. Genau, Fido-Netz.
Ah, genau.
Mehrbox-Netze. Muss ja auch nochmal ein Thema sein. Gut, ich wollte mal darauf hinaus, was kulturell für dich Internet da bedeutet, hat. Und zwar als Musiker, einerseits, aber auch als Teil dieser Technokultur. Was hat das für einen Einfluss gehabt? Und was hat das auf dich für einen Einfluss gehabt? Oder auch die Szene für einen Einfluss gehabt?
Ich meine, es war halt irgendwie, du hattest die Community jetzt nicht mehr nur im Club, sondern du hattest eine sehr breite deutschlandweite Community. In dem Moment, wo die ersten vorhin entstanden, warst du jetzt halt nicht mehr darauf angewiesen, im Club unbedingt nur mit den Leuten zu quatschen, sondern du konntest die Gespräche dann über Internet weiterführen. Oder du konntest dich mit Leuten connecten aus anderen Städten und darüber halt irgendwie auch nicht nur Bookings machen, aber auch mit Leuten irgendwie Dinge abklären, abchecken irgendwie, dass und das passiert in der und der Stadt, irgendwie hier finden Veränderungen so und so statt. Also hauptsächlich eine Kommunikationsebene, eine neue Kommunikationsebene hast du dadurch geschaffen.
Hat das auch fürs Musikmachen eine Rolle gespielt?
Äh, eher weniger. Also ich hab mich über Musik, ich hab meine ganzen Produzentenfähigkeiten eigentlich übers Internet gelernt, weil es halt schon damals irgendwie immer Tutorials oder sonstige Sachen gab, oder auch voran, wo Leute die gleichen Probleme hatten. Damals zum Beispiel war MIDI noch ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln. Und du hattest zum Beispiel MIDI, wie heißen die, MIDI-Interface gehabt irgendwie, du hast einen Rechner angeschlossen, es ging nicht. Vorher musstest du damit zum Musikladen...
Nicht so viel dran gehen.
Auf jeden Fall war das vorher halt immer eine Rennerei zwischen Musikladen und wieder zurück irgendwie. Und da hast du dann plötzlich halt irgendwie auch Leute gefunden, die das gleiche Problem hatten und wo du dann innerhalb von ein paar Stunden das Problem auch lösen konntest. Die sagten dir dann halt, okay, mit dem Mac funktioniert dieses Interface nicht, auch wenn sie dir im Laden was anderes erzählen, es funktioniert nicht irgendwie. Okay, dann hast du halt schon das Problemlösung gehabt. Interessant war dann auch irgendwann Sampletausch zum Beispiel. Man hat selber Sachen gesampelt irgendwie und hatte irgendwelche anderen Musiker oder auch Trecker teilweise. Mit Trecker habe ich dann Sachen getauscht, einfach Samples tauschen. Ich habe das und das abgesampelt, hast du das und das, hast du ein gutes 909-Set da irgendwie, ja klar, kann ich hier schicken und so weiter. Also einfach so Sounds hin und her schicken.
Das ist ja schon relevant für das Musikmachen.
Ja, aber es war damals nicht so, dass man jetzt sagen konnte, es hat jetzt alles geändert. Es war halt eine neue Ebene. Vorher hast du sowas halt irgendwie getauscht auf CD. Aber jetzt ist es halt mit Leuten machen, die du nie getroffen hast. Aber das war in allen Ebenen über Internet so. Das war jetzt nicht speziell für Musiker so. Und dann, ab 1998, wurde es ja auch damit nebsterelevant. Als dann plötzlich Musik irgendwie über Internet zu tauschen war. Nicht nur einzelne Samples, sondern ganze Tracks plötzlich. Ich kann mich dann noch an ein Gespräch mit Tim Renner erinnern, von dem ich ja damals unter Vertrag war. Und der fand das damals alles gar nicht so relevant, weil über ESDN Musik tauschen, wen interessiert das eigentlich? Also das könnte schneller werden und dann geht das verdammt schnell irgendwie. Dann dauert es keine fünf Minuten mehr, bis du so einen Track drüben hast. Aber irgendwie, das wollte er damals ja auch gar nicht so sehen. Aber ich meine, damals gab es ja noch keine Verwendung.
Hattest du dir denn dann mal die Verwertungsrechte dann irgendwie sichern können für deine Musik, dass du da...
Für mein Album habe ich die Verwertungsrechte bei mir, weil Tim Renner meinte, das wäre nicht so wichtig.
Mit dem Internet?
Also das Album könnte ich theoretisch, ich bin da jetzt rechlich nicht so bewandert, aber rein theoretisch habe ich die Internetrechte und könnte es einfach ins Internet stellen, quasi.
Aber was hast du denn gedacht, als so Napstar vor deinem geistigen und dann auch physikalischen Auge auftauchte? Also ich meine, so dieses, dieser Mechanismus, dieses alle bieten auf einmal Musik an, dann ist ja immer dieses, so eine leidige Diskussion, so ein bisschen. Ich will die jetzt auch nicht bis, ich will die jetzt nicht komplett aufmachen, aber so dieses Verhältnis vom Musiker zu dem Netzphänomen Musiktausch ist ja ein gestörtes Phänomen.
Also für mich war ab dem Moment, ab dem letzten Aufkampf klar, dass Musik einen Wert verlieren wird. Ich hatte damals noch zwei Labels und habe dann halt schon gedacht, so okay, also hier ist jetzt ein Damm gebrochen irgendwie.
Welche Labels waren das?
Bash und Timing. Also das eine war für Breakbeat-Sachen, das war Timing, das andere Bash, da hatten wir halt mehr Techno-Sachen drauf gemacht. Aber in dem Moment, wo Napster kam, habe ich schon gesehen, okay, also allein schon aus meinem Plattensammler-Bewusstsein heraus, okay, wenn jetzt plötzlich alles verfügbar ist, wird Musik einfach weniger wert, weil früher hattest du Platten gesammelt, also auch als DJ war es halt essentiell, du hattest eine Platte, die kein anderer hat. Das hat dein Set halt aufgewertet. Und plötzlich waren diese Sachen überall verfügbar. Gut, jetzt im Techno-Bereich noch nicht so, aber du konntest irgendwie die Linie länger ziehen und sagen, okay, also wenn da jetzt noch mehr so Leute ihren Techno reinbringen, oder es gab damals zum Beispiel...
Ja gut, aber haben allein spielt ja nicht die Rolle. Man muss ja auch wissen, dass man es hat und dem einen gewissen Wert bei Mengen und dann auch für ein Set auswählen. Dieser Prozess stirbt ja natürlich nicht.
In dem Moment vorbei, in dem Moment, dass frei verfügbar ist und du zum Beispiel hast es in einem Set und jeder andere kann es auch haben. Früher war halt irgendwie eine Platte aus Amerika gekommen und du warst der Erste, der sie hatte und konnte sie in seinem Set spielen. Das ist in dem Moment mit Napster obsolet geworden, weil in dem Moment, wo du es kriegen konntest, konnten es auch alle anderen kriegen.
Ist es theoretisch obsolet geworden oder gab es dann wirklich diesen Trend, dass die Leute... Es wurde ja eigentlich nicht vom Computer her aufgelegt.
In dem Moment war das noch überhaupt nicht relevant, weil es gab nichts, wo ich das in einem Club hätte abspielen können. Also sogar die Pioneer-CD-Player hätten noch nicht einen MP3 spielen können. Ich hätte es zu einem Wave machen können, aber CD-Player im Club war damals auch noch völlig... Hat kaum stattgefunden. Also es war damals... Ich konnte nur einfach die Linie weiterziehen. Ich wusste in dem Moment, wo Napster aufkam, okay, jetzt wird Musik über Internet aktuell. Und das hat Implikationen, die kann man sich noch nicht ausrechnen.
Was meinst du mit das Verlierten Wert? Redest du jetzt von dem kommerziellen Wert oder von einer Wertschätzung? Also welches...
Alles. Es verliert an jeglichen Werken. Es verliert auch an Nutzungsdauer zum Beispiel. Also in dem Moment, wo eine Sache digital wird, ist es genauso wie mit den News, die digital werden. Sachen, die... Also zum Beispiel Nachrichten konnten sich damals viel länger halten. Du hast vielleicht morgens in der Zeitung gelesen, abends in der Tagesschau die Nachbereitung bei der Bearbeitung gehört. Heute ist es ja so, dass du morgens was auf Spiegel unterliest, was abends gar nicht mehr in den Nachrichten vorkommt, weil schon ganz andere Sachen passiert sind irgendwie. Und genauso passiert es auch mit Musik. Früher, als ich angefangen Musik zu hören habe, habe ich eine Platte gekauft und habe die einen Monat durchgehört. Später, mit Kassetten irgendwie wurde es schneller. Es gab mehr Musik, man hat mehr Musik gehört. Ende der 80er hat man sich jede Woche ein paar Platten gekauft und hat die dann ein paar Wochen später nicht mehr gehört. Und in dem Moment, wo die Maxi aufkamen, bei Techno, hat irgendwie eine Maxi vielleicht in einem Set einen Monat überstanden. Und in dem Moment, wo die Sache digital wird, geht es noch schneller. Maxi-Single?
Ist was drauf? Auch nur ein Lied?
Eine oder zwei Stücke. Ich gehe mal vom DJ aus. Andere kennen das vielleicht gar nicht.
Ja, Schallplatten, das ist ja auch schon fast fossil. Und Chaosradio Express wird ja auch noch in 500 Jahren gehört. Von daher muss man das auch mal...
Eine Maxi-Single ist so groß wie ein Plattenalbum, aber es wird auf 45 abgespielt und von daher entsprechend kürzer. Es sind meistens nur ein oder zwei Tracks drauf. Das war dann halt nur noch für den DJ gedacht. Also der sollte die in sein Set spielen. Und auch da habe ich schon gemerkt, also früher, als ich in den 70ern eine Lezepin LP gekauft habe, habe ich die einen Monat gehört. Als ich in den 80ern, was weiß ich, eine Techno Maxi gekauft habe, habe ich die kaum noch selber gehört, sondern drei- oder viermal in meinem Set aufgelegt. Wenn sie richtig gut war, einen Monat lang im Set aufgelegt. Und in dem Moment, wo die Sache digital wird, ist es ja nochmal eine Beschleunigung.
Es wird auch mehr produziert.
Ja, es wird auch noch mehr produziert, eben. Die Produktionsbedingungen sind ja auch eine ganz andere geworden. Während eine Band in den 70ern noch ein großes Studio mieten musste und da monatelang drin gearbeitet hat, bis es seine Tracks zusammen hatte.
Aber du sagst nicht, dass es schlecht ist, sondern du sagst, so ist es. Du hast ja einfach gesehen, irgendwie NEPSA kam, die nächste Änderungswelle wird anstehen. Mir fällt übrigens wieder Kraftwerk ein. Ich hab die irgendwann mal live gesehen, schon eine Weile her. Ich war schwer beeindruckt von dieser ganzen, haben wir ja schon beschrieben, dieses aseptische Auftreten da, wie sie da kommen. Und vor allem, dass sie auch nichts sagen. Sie sind vollkommen kommentarlos auf die Bühne, begrüßen gar nicht, einer nach dem anderen laufen an ihrer Polte, fangen an, ihren Rädchen dran zu drehen. Zwischendurch ein bisschen Roboter, da sind sie auch nicht auf der Bühne, da kommen sie nochmal wieder. Und dann kam irgendwann Taschenrechner. Und ich fand das irgendwie alles ganz toll. Das war so diese Tour, als sie ihr erstes großes Remix-Album gemacht haben. Und dann nimmt er so ein Gerät, was auch sehr arkan war. Das war irgendwie so ein Stück Metall mit irgendwie einer Taste oder so drauf. Ich stand jetzt nicht direkt daneben, mit einem dicken, fetten, langen Kabel da dran und reichte das so in das Publikum. Das war der erste Moment, wo sie mir wirklich zugegeben haben, dass es auch ein Publikum gibt. Das habe ich einfach nur so ihre Show durchgeführt haben. Und es war halt Taschenrechner. Und wenn ich diese Taste drücke, spielt ja ein kleines Musikstück. Und gaben sozusagen den Leuten die Möglichkeit, die Taste zu drücken und dann spielte es, ich weiß nicht, es gab irgendeine Interaktion. Und dann nahm er das Ding dann, nachdem die ein bisschen damit gespielt haben, nahm er das dann wieder zurück und richtete das erste Mal per Mikrofon dann auch seine Stimme an die Teilnehmer und sagte, jeder kann elektronische Musik machen. Das war dann auch schon die ganze Ansage, bei den ganzen Kram, am Ende wurde noch mal kurz Tschüss gesagt, das war es dann aber auch. Und das habe ich dann als eine interessante Botschaft mitgenommen, dass sie so sagen, naja, auch wenn wir jetzt hier so eine Kathedrale machen, die eigentliche Botschaft lautet, jeder kann elektronische Musik machen. Genau das ist ja im Prinzip auch passiert. Mittlerweile ist ja Musik machen gar nicht mehr so das, was nur so die Musiker machen sollen. Man wird einfach so, wie man heute irgendwie auch Hobbygrafiker ist, zunehmend im Maße auch schon zum Hobbymusiker, weil einfach die Produktionsbedingungen sich so radikal geändert haben. Aber wie siehst du denn das jetzt so mit dem weiteren Verlauf? Du bist ja auch so ein bisschen engagiert. Wenn ich es richtig sehe, bist du ja auch bei den Piraten ein wenig aktiv geworden oder hast du dich da zumindest ein bisschen verfangen? Was war da deine Intention?
Ich habe bei denen auf dem Truck bei dieser Freiheit statt Angst-Demo aufgelegt. Also das war schon ein erhebendes Gefühl. Das war so nachberät auf eine eigentlich recht ernst gemeinten Demo. Ich bin kein Mitglied oder so, aber ich habe mich denen angeschlossen, weil ich halt ihre Thesen für die Wahl sehr richtig fand. Beziehungsweise waren sie das einzige größere Antipotenzial zu diesem ganzen Online-Durchsuchungsscheiß, der halt vor der Wahl passiert ist und diesem ganzen Zensursulogramm. Und von daher haben sie mich halt gefragt, ob ich da Lust hätte, auf dem Truck aufzulegen. Ich so, ja, super, gerne irgendwie. Ich finde, deren Politikmodell, das Wahlprogramm über Wiki zu erstellen, findet endlich mal einen richtigen Weg, mit so einer neueren Politik umzugehen, anstatt irgendwie ständig hinter Zimmer und wir haben beschlossen, unser Oberzampano hat jetzt so Folgendes zu verkünden, finde ich halt diese Art irgendwie, muss ich sagen, da sympathisiere ich mit.
Aber gerade diese Piratenbewegung hat ja auch so ein bisschen ihren Ursprung, gerade in diesem Napster Filesharing, Musik und andere Dateien-Tauschding, auch wenn es natürlich in Deutschland eine ganz andere politische Dimension nochmal bekommen hat, weil es ja auch so eine netzpolitische Tradition ja in Deutschland gibt, schon seit ewigen Zeiten, das schon immer sehr bürgerrechtlich mehr unter Datenschutzaspekten lief als darunter, aber es ist ja im Prinzip auch ein Ausdruck eben dieses zeitlichen Wandels, dieses gesellschaftlichen Wandels, den wir hier die ganze Zeit schon beobachten. Wie passt denn das für dich jetzt zusammen? Was siehst du denn da so für Konsequenzen aus diesen Entwicklungen eines freien, freien netzwerkbildenden Internetses, wo die Leute zusammenkommen, wo sie quasi digitaler Mauerfall spielen die ganze Zeit?
Ich finde, das ist ein laufender Prozess irgendwie. Und ich sehe da immer Schwierigkeiten, da jetzt irgendwie sozusagen, okay, ich muss, also viele meiner Kollegen sehen das immer noch als eine Bedrohung an. Also ihre Musik wird weniger wert, sie können nicht mehr von der Musik leben. Wo ich sagen muss, es ist einfach ein Zeichen der Zeit. Man kann sich nicht gegen wehren. Also man darf es auch nicht als ein Böse, also als was Böses empfinden, sondern man muss halt gucken, wie kann man die ganze Sache weiterentwickeln. Also ich sehe zum Beispiel, also wenn jeder jetzt produzieren kann, für sich alleine, kann es auch wieder Möglichkeiten geben, wo Leute zusammen miteinander Sachen produzieren. Also die Technik, die kommt jetzt auch so voran. Ich kann mir vorstellen, über Google Wave zum Beispiel, das ist sowas wie ein Riesen, oder das ist die ein Gadget bauen, wo dann Leute miteinander Musik zielen können, über weite Entfernung, oder Ableton baut das auch gerade ein. Ich finde also, das ist ein laufender Prozess und bloß weil man jetzt im Moment nicht unbedingt irgendwie in der Phase der Entwicklung als Musiker nicht mehr unbedingt davon leben kann. Heißt es nicht, dass dann eine Entwicklung wieder entsteht, wo sich neue Sachen draus bilden, irgendwie dass man davon leben kann. Und das aus dem Status Quo heraus zu beurteilen, ich kann meine Musik nicht verkaufen oder keiner kauft mehr Platten oder ein altes Medium oder sowas. Ist halt einfach so. Muss man mit dealen, muss ich halt irgendwie überlegen, wie organisiere ich mich dann anders, außer mein Jugendtraum geht nicht mehr oder so. Die Zeit geht weiter.
Ja und ich meine, wie du es dem persönlich so begegnet? Ich meine, wenn die Modelle, mit denen du vorher Geld verdient hast, jetzt nicht mehr greifen, welche haben das dann sozusagen abgelöst?
Ich zum Beispiel mache noch andere Jobs. Ich arbeite für einen Audioportal und bearbeite Audiophiles zum Beispiel. Oder ich bringe für dieses Audioportal Labels in das Portal rein und versuche halt irgendwie da drüber, auch noch Geld zu generieren. Ich lege halt weiterhin auf. Es ist ja auch dieses Ding geworden, das ein Musiker heute produzieren muss, damit er Gigs kriegt zum Beispiel. Du machst nicht mehr das Geld über die Platte wie in 90ern oder über die Zensierung der Platte, sondern dadurch, dass du danach auflegst. Aber zum Beispiel, das ist auch bei dieser ganzen Diskussion, wenn dann zum Beispiel die Piraten sagen, ja, jetzt muss der Künstler halt in Zukunft auftreten, da weiß er halt letzter Schluss, weil es gibt genug Musiker, die es gar nicht drauf haben, jetzt aufzulegen oder einen Live-Ect machen zu wollen. Man kann halt dieses ganze Konzert...
Oder deren Musik auch dafür gar nicht taugt.
Ja, oder wenn ein 60-Jähriger, willst du einen 60-Jährigen das nochmal durch die Welt schicken, irgendwie dem sagen, ok, hast du schon eine schöne Platte gemacht, aber um jetzt was zu verdienen, musst du halt jetzt nach Timbuktu fliegen oder so.
Auf den Rave.
Es gibt halt im Moment keinen... Da weiß er halt letzter Schluss, es gibt es einfach nicht. Sondern man muss halt irgendwie... Ich glaube auch nicht, dass Musik nur frei sein müsste oder dass Musik nur bezahlt sein sollte, sondern dass in Zukunft auch verschiedene Konzepte greifen müssen. Sowohl Bezahlkonzepte als auch Freikonzepte. Dass das aber letztendlich auch bei dem Künstler liegt, wie er sich vermarktet oder wo er sich anschließen will. Also es gibt in Zukunft mehrere Strömungen und man muss halt sehen, wo er bleibt sozusagen. Man muss ja nicht von der Musik selber leben, sondern es gibt noch genug Bereiche irgendwie, wo man sich auch irgendwie reintun kann bei der Musik. Also durch das Digitale entstehen ja auch neue Bereiche, über die man auch Geld verdienen könnte oder seinen Unterhalt verdienen könnte.
Kommen wir nochmal vielleicht wieder zurück zum Techno, den wir ja so ein bisschen jetzt so auf seinem Höhepunkt schon fast verlassen haben wieder. Ich glaube, es gibt natürlich eine Menge Sachen, die man jetzt so aufgreifen kann. Love Parade so als Phänomen in Erinnerung. Ich meine, jetzt gibt es zwar eigentlich noch, aber eigentlich ist es ja vorbei.
Ja, das war, bis 97 war es eine lustige Veranstaltung. Also der Anfang, 89, war super. Solange es auf dem Kudern war, war es auch noch super. Aber in dem Moment, wo halt irgendwie diese Kommerzialisierung einsetzt, wie bei den meisten Sachen, in dem Moment, wo die Kommerzialisierung einsetzt, ist die Sache eigentlich vorbei. Weil dann ziehst du die falschen Leute an, es werden die falschen Ziele, es ist nicht mehr um der Sache willen, sondern andere Faktoren treten in den Vordergrund und beerdigen das eigentlich. Dann kommen dann auch so Anfeindungen. Du merkst auch schon, wenn die Kontrollebene irgendwie unter sich nicht mehr eins ist oder sowas, dann gehen Sachen meistens unter. Das war bei der Loveberede halt spätestens 97 der Fall. Für mich eigentlich schon ab 95, 96 habe ich schon gemerkt, hm, schmeckt ein bisschen bitter jetzt irgendwie. Und ab 97 war ich auch nicht mehr dabei.
Jetzt nur, weil es so voll wird oder?
Ja, weil auch diese halt irgendwie damals mit die Frontpage zusammen mit Low Spirit und Loveberede halt irgendwie so ein Konsortium gebildet haben, die halt irgendwie aus Techno das gemacht hatten, wo ich niemals hinwollte. Also so eine Verdummung der Massen irgendwie. Kommt zu uns, ihr seid alle willkommen, lasst euer Geld hier. Wir finden euch toll, egal wie ihr seid, aber ist es für jeden Platz. Und es ist oftmals halt so, also am Anfang, das habe ich ja auch gemerkt, irgendwie bei mir irgendwie, am Anfang war es ja auch so wirklich, dass man für jeden sagen wollte, na klar, hier ist für jeden Platz oder sowas, aber es gibt dann auch irgendwann den Punkt, wo man sagen muss, okay, es reicht. Ab hier gibt es dann genug Leute, die brauchen es dann auch bitte nicht mehr verstehen, weil man muss nicht jeden Mob irgendwie ansprechen. Man kann auch ruhig sagen, okay, ab hier wird es avantgarde und wer es nicht kapiert, bitte draußen bleiben irgendwie. Und das war halt bei Techno so, hätte ich gedacht, ab 95 hätte man das ruhig sagen können. Okay, ab hier bitte nicht mehr irgendwie, weil jetzt kommt wirklich nur noch der Mob dazu, wie auch MySpace heute zum Beispiel. Das war am Anfang eine super Plattform, um Musiker und Leute zusammenzubringen, aber wenn du siehst, was ich da heute noch anmelde, wo dann auch so hast du, irgendwann ist dann auch mal Ende im Melende und die kritische Masse ist irgendwie drüber und man kann es dann eigentlich vergessen irgendwie. Es wird dann immer bunter und immer für alle, also der gemeinsame Nenner wird immer niedriger und es wird dann irgendwann nur noch blech.
Aber es ist natürlich schwierig, sich dazu entziehen und zu sagen, jetzt wo es so populär ist, lassen wir es sein.
Ja, aber dann siehst du halt auch, dass es nur noch ums Geld geht irgendwie und das war halt immer, wenn die Sache halt so geldgebunden ist, dann ist es eigentlich langweilig, so ergebnisorientiert irgendwie. Also diese ergebnisorientierte Kunst überhaupt, ergebnisorientierte Schaffen irgendwie, macht es meistens langweilig.
Du plädierst sozusagen mehr für so eine prozessorientierte Kunst.
Ja, einfach Sachen machen lassen irgendwie. Also auch auf die Gefahr hin, dass irgendwie mal dabei was kaputt geht oder so. Das ist mir lieber, als wenn dieser Mammon im Vordergrund steht. Aus meiner Karriere heraus oder aus meinem Wirken heraus kann ich auch wirklich sagen, so langfristig irgendwie einfach sehen, es für sich möglichst angenehm zu machen. Oder wie soll man sagen, sich möglichst treu zu bleiben und dabei auch Brüche zu riskieren. Das finde ich auf jeden Fall spannender und auch positiver, als irgendwann zu sagen, ok, jetzt geht es mir nur noch ums Geld. Weil dann ist die Sache eigentlich vorbei.
Diese Techno-Zeit in Berlin, da gibt es ja echt so viele Aspekte, also nicht nur in Berlin, aber in Berlin auch immer im Besonderen. Gerade so dieses Hin und Her mit der Gesellschaft, so dieses Katz-und-Maus-Spiel, was dann auch irgendwann eingesetzt hat, die Zeit, ab 1993 meintest du, fing so ein bisschen an, der Staat, die Gesellschaft, die Ordnung, so ein bisschen diesen Technohaufen zusammenzuzurren und versucht ihn so ein bisschen handlebar zu machen. Wobei ich immer wieder erstaunlich fand, wie sehr sich da dann so eine Kreativität geweckt hat, um sich dem dann auch zu entziehen. Die Love Brake gehört ja im Prinzip als Demonstration angemeldet auch schon so ein bisschen dazu. Da zieht man irgendwie raus und sagt, Friede, Freude, Eierkuchen, das ist jetzt mal hier unsere Forderung. Dafür gehen wir auf die Straße. Egal, was daraus geworden ist, das war auf jeden Fall schon mal ein sehr knackiger Ansatz. Es ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch so ein bisschen eine Parallele zu diesem, was du schon gesagt hast, dieses keine Texte mehr. Keine Indoktrination, jetzt mal nicht denkt dieses, denkt das, sondern einfach denkt auch mal, was ihr wollt. Das steckt da ja auch so ein bisschen mit drin. Dann gab es auch noch so Nebenaspekte. Hattest du nicht auch mal was mit diesem Vereinsheim 1892 zu tun? War das nicht der erste Laden, der auch diese Problematik der Clubbildung dadurch umgangen hat, dass man dann so temporär Mitglied wurde?
Ja, genau. Also damals ging es halt irgendwie darum, es dürften keine Clubs mehr. Also die Stadt sagte irgendwie so, Clubs wollen wir jetzt eigentlich mehr, haben wir jetzt genug irgendwie, reicht jetzt. Und wir hätten für dieses Gebäude damals an der Schillingbrücke, hätten wir keine Gedämmigung als Club gekriegt. Wir hatten auch gar nicht das Geld, das Ding als Club jetzt herzurichten. Wir haben einfach gesagt, okay, wir machen jetzt einen Verein zur Förderung der elektronischen Musik. Und jedes Wochenende machen wir eine Veranstaltung.
Für die Vereinsmitglieder?
Für die Vereinsmitglieder, aber du musst halt dich halt nicht einschreiben. Du kannst auch irgendwie für das Wochenende dem Verein beitreten oder für die Veranstaltung irgendwie ein Obolus lassen, dann bist du auch drin. Und wir mussten halt uns dann halten irgendwie einmal im Monat glaube ich irgendeine Vorsitzendenrunde da irgendwie und irgendwas beschließen irgendwie. Was habt ihr denn da so beschlossen? Na zum Beispiel, dass da ein neues Laminat rein muss.
Dass das alles durchgetanzt ist.
Dass die Wand dann neu gestrichen werden muss. Und dass die Bar irgendwie da blöd steht, weil da rennen die Leute ständig dran.
Ja, also im Kegelklub alle Neune wird jetzt auch nicht über sehr viele andere Sachen gesprochen.
Also dass man in so einem Verein halt irgendwie sprechen muss.
Das hat gut funktioniert.
Ja, nur einmal im Monat geht das schon. Das hat man sich halt gemütlich gemacht, auf dem Mittwochabend irgendwie.
Nee, ich meine jetzt nicht das Treffen, sondern überhaupt dieses Ganze. Weil da war ja dann auch er jedes Wochenende.
Naja, also am Anfang hat mir das sehr gut gefallen, weil es dann halt ein schöner Ansatz war. Aber das Ding ist dann irgendwann in Glitten irgendwie. Also das war dann wirklich so, wirklich halt wirklich so eine Drogenhülle geworden. Also das hat irgendwann im Sommer angefangen irgendwie. Da war ich noch sehr engagiert bei der Sache. Im Herbst irgendwie war das dann schon sehr seltsam. Da waren manchmal Vorfälle gewesen, wo ich gedacht habe, was passiert denn hier? Und dann war ich irgendwann mal ein paar Wochen im Urlaub und komme zurück und habe dann meine letzte Schicht irgendwie vom Wochenende gefahren. Das war morgens um 6 Uhr und da habe ich mir gedacht, was für Leute spielst du hier eigentlich? Was macht die denn sonst im Leben? Also es waren wirklich Wracks, die da morgens um 6 Uhr rumgelegen haben. Und habe mich dann aus der Sache dann verabschiedet, weil das war mir echt too much. Also das war nichts gegen wirklich Hedonismus und alles Mögliche, aber irgendwie das war wirklich so abgefuckt und fertig. Und nee, konnte ich mich wirklich da überhaupt nicht mehr mit identifizieren. Also das Ding ist richtig in die Glitten am Schluss.
Ach ja, da sind wir wieder beim Exzess. Ja, aber was kann man jetzt für Lehren draus ziehen aus dieser Zeit? Also inwiefern haben sich denn jetzt auch Modelle da entwickelt, die dann nicht nach zwei Jahren voll gescheitert sind? Du hast ja schon gesagt, damals haben sich Netzwerke gebildet, die auch heute noch halten. Haben sich jetzt nur Personenkreise da gefunden, die sich immer noch kennen? Oder meinst du damit auch, es haben sich Formen der Kommunikation und Kollaborationen herausgebildet, die heute auch noch so funktionieren?
Alles Mögliche. Also es haben sich alle möglichen Arten und Untergruppierungen so was gebildet. Also wenn du heute auf Facebook hast, also mein Facebook besteht eigentlich nur aus Leuten, mit denen ich damals feiern war. Also Leute, die das...
Richter muss ja auch schon immer beitreten.
Nee, eine Fanpage, nee. Ich finde Fanpage ist blöd. Also so meine normale Seite. Und das ist auch immer meine, sage ich auch immer, also ich habe auch schon einigen Leuten abgesagt und habe gesagt, also ich habe mit dir noch nicht eine Nacht durchgefeiert, ich kenne dich so nicht, ich nehme dich da nicht auf. Also das ist halt, diese Netzwerke, die entwickeln sich auch weiter. Also Leute, mit denen ich früher Lebens gemacht habe, mit denen kommuniziere ich heute über Facebook zum Beispiel. Aber auch, ja, auch so dieses Miteinander, also dieses Vertrauen, dass du damals zu Leuten gewonnen hast, das hat sich dann auch teilweise bis heute noch fortgesetzt. Also das war natürlich teilweise auch dann drogeninduziert, dass da halt, ey Mann, du bist ganz anders halt, sicher, auf einer Ebene und so. Aber du hast dann zu den Zeiten auch zu Leuten ein Vertrauen entwickelt irgendwie, wo du wusstest, okay, also jetzt Business willst du nicht unbedingt mit denen machen, aber du kannst dich ansonsten voll auf die verlassen. Und das hält auch bis heute an. Und auch Techno in sich existiert ja bis heute. Also es ist wieder aus dem Fokus der Massenmedien herausgefallen. Also gut, jetzt kam es halt wieder durch ein paar Bücher, ein paar Filme rein. Aber auch nachdem dieser Hype vorbei war oder so, hat sich die Sache ja immer noch weiterentwickelt und ist einfach nicht totzukriegen. Wenn du jetzt heute siehst, im Berghain spielen DJs zusammen mit dem Ballett vom Staatstheater oder so was. Also da sind ja Sachen passiert irgendwie. Da träumt Rock heute noch von. Also diese Netzwerke, die haben auch nicht aufgehört zu existieren, sondern du siehst Leute, einige sind in Positionen, was weiß ich, irgendwo staatlich als Beamte irgendwie, aber haben halt irgendwie immer noch den Zugriff auf diese Technosanleitung. Du hast ja immer noch Ansprechpartner in allen möglichen Positionen irgendwie. Also das ist nach wie vor sehr virulent.
Der Marsch durch die Institutionen sozusagen.
Ja, das ist immer noch sehr virulent. Also passiert immer überall noch was. Nicht mehr jetzt so im Fokus der Medien, aber eigentlich mehr als damals, nur nicht mehr im Fokus.
Es gab ja damals auch schon so einige Bestrebungen, so ein bisschen schon, während das alles noch in voller Fahrt war, das eigene kulturelle Werk sich zu erarbeiten. Ich erinnere mich an so Sachen wie Chroma Park zum Beispiel, eine Ausstellung im E-Werk. Ich weiß nicht, ob Ausstellung die richtige Bezeichnung ist. Der versucht so ein bisschen so die Gegenwartskultur im Kontext Techno einzuordnen.
Das fand ich damals gar nicht so falsch, weil die Außenwelt hat ja gar nicht mitgekriegt, was an Kunst, die aus Techno entstanden ist, an Visueller, was da alles existiert. Das mal in den Fokus zu bringen, fand ich damals gar nicht so verkehrt. Nur die Auswahl fand ich teilweise ein bisschen... Da waren halt Sachen dabei, wo ich gesagt hätte, naja, hab ich vorher nie gesehen, hab ich danach nie wieder gesehen. Da ging es auch so ein bisschen mit Fetternwirtschaft durch. Aber es gab auch bis heute noch diese VJ-Camps zum Beispiel. Das finde ich nach wie vor super. Wenn sich die Techniken weiterentwickeln und dann so Camps da draußen stehen, wo man sich halt irgendwie miteinander verständigt.
Wollte ich vorhin noch erwähnen, hab ich vergessen. Aber jetzt mache ich es einfach mal. Es gab ja schon ein Chaosradio Express zu dem Thema, CRE 96. Ein Freund von mir, Falk, gerade diesen ganzen Bereich VJ-Kultur, Live-Cinema und was sich da so über die Zeit entwickelt hat, auch nochmal besprochen habe. Das musste ich jetzt nochmal hier kurz einwerfen. Aber davon abgesehen jetzt von diesem VJ-Kram, was ja auch glaube ich beim Chroma-Park unter anderem im Mittelpunkt stand, war ja auch so dieser Aspekt der Deko. Also dass so ein Rave gestaltet wird. Das war ja auch nicht unbedingt selbstverständlich. Selbstverständlich hat natürlich jeder Club irgendwie Licht und Bild oder so. Aber es ging ja teilweise so weit, dass Partys ja unter ein Motto gestellt wurden und dann dieses Motto dann auch irgendwie alles durchwirkte. Und dass Leute sich dort engagiert haben, um dann einfach diese Partys auch rein visuell vor Ort zu einem Erlebnis zu machen.
Das war in den 90ern auch noch gut möglich.
Da gab es dann auch die Räume. Das war natürlich auch eine Herausforderung. Und auch schon die gescholtene Frontpage, über die man jetzt geteilter Meinung sein kann, inwieweit sie da jetzt kulturellen Beitrag geleistet hat, war natürlich an sich auch ein Phänomen. Allein schon dieses grafische Erscheinungsbild, diese Unlesbarkeit, dieses mega-experimentelle mit Schrift durchzuführen und einfach bewusst auch zu sagen, ja hier, da ist die Verlautbarung unserer neuen Kulturszene. Lest doch, wenn ihr könnt. Aber ihr könnt wahrscheinlich gar nicht, weil wir sind ja so anders. Das wird euch jetzt erstmal schwerfallen. An der Stelle hat man natürlich auch schon das Avantgarde-Schild in der Hand gehabt, was du vorhin ja noch eingeklagt hast, gesagt haben, naja gut, aber wir machen es euch jetzt auch nicht zu einfach. Das fand ich immer sehr spannend, auch wenn ich mit einzelnen Sachen jetzt nicht was anfangen konnte. Es gibt ja viele Namen, die damit verbunden sind, was weiß ich hier so, die Gestalten und so ähnliche Gruppierungen, die ja dann auch so eine ganz einfache, ganz außergewöhnliche Bildsprache auch entwickelt haben, die dann auch Ausdruck der Zeit war.
Ja, also, Frontpete hatte immer ein sehr ambivalentes Verhalten. Am Anfang hatte ich halt, ich hatte sogar mit Lamern ja best ursprünglich gegründet als Label, also dem Macher von Frontpete, hatte da auch Reviews geschrieben am Anfang für die Platten. Und irgendwann hatte ich von dem Laden einfach die Nase voll, weil es war halt irgendwie diese Verbindung mit Spirit und Media und so weiter. Du hast halt gemerkt, es sollte jetzt so dieses Verlautbarungsblatt werden. Es gab natürlich einen Schmück, der die Grafik gemacht hat, der Kumpel Tillmann, der da drin sozusagen für die Bilder und den Humor zuständig war. Das waren ja immer noch widerstrebende Sachen. Man hätte niemals sagen können, die Frontpage ist nur scheiße oder die Frontpage ist nur gut. Es gab halt auch da widerstrebende Kräfte, die trotzdem da gebündelt werden und dadurch erst das Heft interessant gemacht hatten. Aber am Schluss war das halt wirklich nur so ein Sponsorendreck gewesen. Scammle, Silverpages und Hausnetwork, was eigentlich nur Adressen sammeln war, damit man die Leute zuspammen kann irgendwie. Aber trotzdem irgendwie als Szenesprachrohr trotzdem nicht zu verachten gewesen. Und meines Erachtens war es damals immer noch besser als Groove oder Revlan oder wie sie alle hießen, weil die halt immer noch so ein Konzept hatten, irgendwie so über das Leser erheben irgendwie. Wir geben euch jetzt mal von oben herab, was ihr hören sollten, was gut ist oder bei der Revlan war es mir immer zu populistisch. Die Frontpage hatte wenigstens immer noch Ecken und Kanten, wo man wirklich sagen konnte, wie können die so einen Scheiß schreiben oder...
Hat sich auch selber sehr viel mehr als Teil der Community auch verstanden. Also es war zumindest der Anspruch.
Naja, also von lahm an der Anspruch war irgendwann eigentlich nur noch Geld zu machen. Das hat mich dem Behelf schon deutlich angemerkt.
Im Laufe der Zeit. Ja, auch wenn es dann vielleicht in ähnlichen Kontext gehört, erwähnen muss man es trotzdem. Diese Mayday-Party-Serie war ja nun auch eine der Sachen, die deutlich so herausgeragt haben aus dieser Zeit.
Ja, die waren ja am Anfang auch super.
Also, das gilt wahrscheinlich jetzt für alles. Also alles war so am Anfang super. Ja, aber am Anfang sind Sachen immer... Ja, okay, dann schauen wir doch einfach mal auf den Anfang. Ich meine, dass die Dinge dann irgendwie entglitten sind, das nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal zur Kenntnis. Das ist, denke ich, ja auch klar. Es ist auch immer dann auch interessant zu sehen, was ist letztlich davon übrig geblieben. Aber was hat es für eine Rolle gespielt zu dem Zeitpunkt, als es neu war?
Also, damit habe ich bis heute noch Streit mit Wolle XDP irgendwie über die Rolle der Mede. Weil wir hatten ja damals mit Technozid, mit den Reves angefangen. Und irgendwie hatte, glaube ich, Los Spirit, von Los Spirit ging ja diese Mede aus, hatten Maruscha damals irgendwie so gefeatured. Und die sollte dann eine Radiosendung kriegen. Dann wurde DT64 geschlossen. Und es war angeblich irgendwie, es hieß Safe DT64. Was aber, glaube ich, nur ein Vorwand war, um diesen Rev zu veranstalten. Trotzdem fand ich ihn nicht schlecht. Weil, während wir mit Technozid damals irgendwie sehr auf Berlin fixiert waren, oder auf eine bestimmte nationale Ausprägung von Techno, hatte die Medie gleich ein Artist-Arsenal aus Amerika, England, Belgien, Deutschland. Das fand ich super. Da kam dann auch eine Kommunikation zwischen den Artists zustande, die nicht nur über Faxe oder so funktioniert, sondern wo man sich von Gesicht zu Gesicht gesehen hat. Daraus sind auch Kollaborationen entstanden, auch zwischen Labels und Artisten. Wolle meinte schon damals, das ist nur, um abzukassieren. Damit haben sie unser Konzept kaputt gemacht. Ich so, naja, Wolle, willst du jetzt irgendwie dieses Ding, weil die Medie hat von Anfang an gesagt, wenn das Ding funktioniert, gehen wir auch nach einer anderen Stätte. Fand ich super. Also irgendwie unsere Idee in andere Städte rüber tragen. Ich so, Wolle, gefragt, willst du das auch machen irgendwie? Gehst du in eine andere Stätte? Nee, auf gar keinen Fall. Ich bin hier in Berlin, wir sind die Wichtigsten, wir machen das hier. Und ich so, naja, dann finde ich das Konzept. Also er wollte mich halt irgendwie dazu bewegen, nicht da mitzumachen, sondern bei Technozie zu bleiben. Und ich habe dann gesagt, naja, das Konzept sehe ich schon ein bisschen anders. Es geht in eine andere Richtung. Und ich möchte dann bei beiden schon mitmachen irgendwie. Und ich fand dann auch die erste Medie war der Hammer. Also als sie in der Halle der Weißen See stattfand. Und es war Sven Väter, es war irgendwie lauter Leute von R&S da. Also damals halt ein sehr bekanntes Label. Es war schon so ein Come Together von verschiedenen Stemmen irgendwie. Also auf so einer Rev-Ebene irgendwie. Und das hat sehr gut funktioniert. Und dann hat die zweite in Köln stattgefunden. So früher, 92. Und da war dann gleich Effigstwin, Moby und die ganzen Leute, die ja damals halt irgendwie aktuell waren. Bis heute auch noch aktuell sind. Also wirklich so der Kern der Technoszene. Alle auf einem Event irgendwie. Und der Event war auch in der Eissporthalle. Alles voll irgendwie, die Leute mit. Also die Leute haben teilweise katastrophal ausgesehen, mit Staugsau auf dem Rücken und so weiter. Das sollte halt irgendwie so future-mäßig sein, aber es war teilweise halt auch wirklich... Ja, es war halt teilweise schon so. Es ist ganz schön straight, George. Aber es gab auch wirklich Leute dabei, die sich wirklich verkleidet haben, wo du wirklich gesagt hast, Hammer, also die haben da wirklich... Es wurde dann nachher dann irgendwie so tot geredet. So, Peter, bei der nächsten Medie, mach das bitte nicht mehr. Und ich hab mir halt gedacht, naja, ist eigentlich aber auch irgendwo schade drum, weil manche Leute haben sich wirklich, also wirklich geile Sachen ausgedacht gehabt. Also da waren Kostüme dabei gewesen, wo du schon gedacht hast, also ist nicht ohne. Also da hat sich jemand einen Kopf gemacht. Aber das ist dann halt auch leider eingeschlafen. Das kam dann halt vor wie die Steigerung des Leuchtstabs irgendwie. Der ganz Körperleuchtstab. Und dann war das halt mit der Zeit irgendwie so immer die Wintermedie fand dann in Berlin statt. Und die Frühjahrsmedie fand dann in Dortmund in dieser riesen Arena statt.
Das waren alle in Westfalen. Wo sie ja auch immer noch einmal in der Jahrstaffheit.
Und ich war dann noch bis 95 und bin dann ausgestiegen. Weil da war mir dann dieser Kommerzgedanke, oder dann kam aus so eine Hierarchie drin vor. Am Anfang war es halt alle auf einer Bühne. Und plötzlich war das halt so, die und die Art, das sind auf einem kleinen Floor irgendwie neben dran. Und dann gibt es die Stars, die auf dem großen Floor auflegen. Und dann gibt es da hinten noch so einen ganz anderen Floor, wo dann noch so kleine aus der Region auflegen und so was. Und dann wurde das Ganze so hierarchisch. Und da hast du richtig gemerkt, wie auch mit so was gespielt wurde. Also von den Veranstaltern her so richtig zu zeigen, du bist jetzt nicht mehr auf dem Hauptfloor, dich machen wir diesmal auf den und den Floor und so was. Also es wurde mir alles so...
Wie war denn das mit dieser internationalen Begegnung? Ich meine, jetzt haben wir ja viel über die Situation in Deutschland und Berlin im Besonderen gesprochen. Trotzdem ist ja Techno auch ein internationales Phänomen geworden. Also sicherlich nicht irgendwie jetzt überall auf diesem Planeten. Aber die westliche Welt hat es schon weitgehend ergriffen. Irgendwann haben, glaube ich, sogar die Amerikaner das gemocht. Weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau. Aber es würde mich interessieren, wie du das so siehst, was eigentlich seitdem passiert ist. Wir haben jetzt auch viel über Musikstile geredet, bis hin zu Techno. Beziehungsweise es gibt ja also diesen einen Sound Techno. In dem Sinne gibt es nicht Techno, das ist halt der Sammelbegriff. Und dann gibt es da irgendwie verschiedene Musikrichtungen, die jetzt alle aufzublättern, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen müßig. Aber vielleicht kann man ja noch mal kurz schildern, wie sich das sozusagen seit seinem Höhepunkt dann weiterentwickelt hat. Also was hat Techno als solches beeinflusst und an Musikstilen vielleicht auch hervorgebracht, die man heute nicht ohne weiteres unter Techno einordnen würde?
Hoho, weites Thema. Also erstmal hatten wir so ab 96 den Zusammenbruch von Techno eigentlich. Also mit dem kommerziellen Einbruch, der so ab 96 passierte, hast du auch so einen Sinneinbruch gehabt, wo dann plötzlich so ein Vakuum entstanden ist. Also erstmal war alles höher, schneller, weiter. Plötzlich war höher, schneller, weiter vorbei. Und ab dem Zeitpunkt war dann auch so die Frage irgendwie, wo sind wir hier? Was hat uns hierher gebracht? Und wo geht es jetzt hier weiter? Und das hat so bis zum Ende des Letzten Jahrtausends eigentlich gedauert. Das war halt irgendwie so ein sehr durcheinander alles gewesen. Du hattest verschiedene Stile, die halt irgendwie sich so teilweise überlagerten, teilweise voneinander differenzierten, teilweise auch gar nichts miteinander zu tun haben wollten. Wir zum Beispiel Techno mit Bregby, den ich damals vertreten habe, das wollte gar nichts eigentlich miteinander zu tun haben. Das war halt so ein Kuddelmuddelzeit gewesen, so drei, vier Jahre Kuddelmuddelzeit. Das hast du auch in der Clublandschaft gemerkt irgendwie. Hier in Berlin gab es dann plötzlich das Planet nicht mehr, also das EWEC nicht mehr, weil was einen riesen Vakuum hinterlassen hat, das dann das Ostgut, Casino und wie sie alle hießen aufgenommen haben, aber halt irgendwie nicht mehr diesen Einheitsstiftenden Charakter hatten. Und das war halt symptomatisch für die ganze Szene. Es gab nicht mehr dieses Einheitsstiftende. Es ist alles auseinandergesprungen, auseinandergesplittert. Und jeder hat von seiner kleinen Scholle aus versucht, bei den anderen anzudocken, aber es hat irgendwie nicht so funktioniert. Und in Westdeutschland hat sich dann so gegen den Rest von Deutschland, außer in Berlin kann man sagen, hat sich zum Ende des Jahrtausends diese Schranz-Techno-Entwicklung ergeben. Ich habe es nie verstanden, es war einfach nur eine dumme, harte Musik, aber ohne Tiefgang oder sowas.
Was war damit jetzt hier so?
Nee, das war so Chris Liebing zu der Zeit, Sven Wittekind, DJ Amok und wie die alle hießen. Also es war halt wirklich so... Also auf 140 BPM und Gbm und Distortion drauf und es klang für mich alles gleich. Ich habe es nie verstanden. Es hat in Berlin auch nicht wirklich funktioniert. Also hier hat es dann so eine andere Entwicklung gegeben. Das war der harte Techno, der immer existierte, sowohl im Tresor als auch im Ostgut. Aber es gab dann einen zweiten Floor, wo dann zu der Zeit kam ein kompakt mit Minimal wieder auf, was zwar nie wirklich weg war, aber einen neuen Schub gekriegt, als Gegenreaktion zu diesem Schranz, wo viele der älteren Klubber, die sowas nicht mehr vertragen haben. Also für mich war auch in Sachen Härte alles ausdefiniert.
Also Senior Techno sozusagen.
Ja, nicht Senior Techno, aber das hatte man schon durch. Also die Auslotung der Härte und der Grenzen der Härte irgendwie, das hatte man einfach hinter sich. Also mit Gabba und Underground Resistance hatten wir da irgendwie so Grenzsteine gesetzt, wo er sagt, okay, also da brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr weiter forschen, sondern da ist jetzt alles wirklich durch.
Gabba war wirklich das metallische Ende, ne?
Das war das schnelle Ende.
Das war wirklich der Anschein. Also ich war einmal, es gab ja diesen gloriosen Clubbunker in einem Bunker in Berlin-Mitte mittendrin. Heute hat sich da irgendein Millionär gekauft und speichert da seine Kunstwerke irgendwie ab. Das war wirklich, ich glaube, das war der absurdeste, das ich je besucht habe. Also ein Bunker, da muss ich so einen langen Gang spiralförmig irgendwie nach oben rekte und da war einfach nur noch Strobo und Lärm. Also es war einfach alles laut und ich weiß nicht, wie Gabba es definieren würde von der Geschwindigkeit, was ist so die Minimalgeschwindigkeit des Beats?
150.
150, aber das ist dann schon eher die Ambient-Variante.
Geht dann hoch bis 200.
Also man fühlt sich wirklich wie in so einem Schlagbohrer eingesperrt. Da muss man dann nichts mehr drauflegen.
Nee, aber es gab ja wirklich zu der Zeit, also den Anfang von Gabba fand ich ja auch noch super irgendwie. Das war halt noch die Steigerung. Die Steigerung von Hardware einfach noch Gabba oder so Sachen wie zum Beispiel Sperminator oder so, wer das kennt irgendwie. Das war einfach, das gehört heute noch für mich zu den Kronjuwelen von Techno dazu. Aber es ist halt immer schlimm, wenn irgendwie so eine Standardisierung gefunden wird und die dann halt auf endlosester Weise durchgezogen wird. Also 200 BPM, Base Drum irgendwie da drüber irgendwie, irgendwelche Samples drüber gefeuert, irgendwas. Und das ist es irgendwie und das dann eine ganze Nacht durch. Also das geht mir bei jedem Stil irgendwann auf den Sender irgendwie, wenn halt so diese Formel gefunden wird und nur noch durchgezogen wird.
Okay, also das waren Dead Ends. Aber was hat sich denn jetzt so entwickelt? Du hast ja vorhin schon Drum und Base, hast du ja schon genannt. Ist das nicht so ein Beispiel für etwas, was sich so aus dem Techno heraus...
Ja, da muss man halt sehen. Am Anfang war ja alles Techno. Und teilweise waren da so Hip-Hop-Beats drunter. Teilweise war eine 9 und 9 einfach drunter mit einem geraden Beat. Das war aber am Anfang beides Techno. Und ab 92 hat sich das dann so aufgetrennt, dass man gesagt hat, okay, die einen sagten, Techno ist nur das mit dem geraden Beat. Die anderen sagten halt, ja, bei uns ist es auch irgendwie Techno, weil in England gilt das als Techno. Da hatten sie halt diese Jungle-Variante oder UK-Hardcore, sagte man damals dazu. Aber es hat sich halt irgendwie so auseinanderentwickelt. In England wurde es halt immer mehr zu Jungle, dann so ab 94, 95 zu Drum und Base. Und in Deutschland, bzw. Deutschland, Detroit, Chicago, da war halt weiter dann dieser gerade Beat, mehr mit Synthesizer, und in England wurde halt der Sampler. Also von jeher, der Sampler war halt immer mehr so das Instrument, zum Rumexperimentieren bei denen. Und da haben sich dann so zwei Schulen drausentwickelt. Also einmal diese Drum-and-Base-Breakbeat-Variante, und zum anderen halt diese sehr synthesizerlastige oder melodielastigere Detroit, Deutschland, Chicago, China. Und naja, also dieses Drum-and-Base, das hat dann von dem Sounddesign her irgendwie so ab 95 dann schon ein ganz schönes Ruder übernommen, meines Erachtens. Also während hier noch irgendwie so mit Synthesizern oder mit 3039 und 99 immer noch das halt weiter exerziert wurde, was man schon durch hatte, wo dann auch irgendwann das Ende der Fahnenstange erreicht war, hat man sich da halt irgendwie ganz andere Soundkosmos schon aufgetan, dadurch, dass man den Sampler so benutzt hat, wie man vorher eigentlich noch nie benutzt hatte. Also die hatten, was da mit Rhythmen angestellt wurde.
Was wurden denn da angestellt?
Also während bei Techno halt irgendwie einfach nur dieser Beat durchlief und vielleicht mal irgendwie gemuted wurde und wieder reingezogen wurde.
Dann schreien alle?
Ja, oder der Bass wurde mal rausgedreht, oder die Hi-Hats gehen mal raus, war halt irgendwie, wenn du so einen Drum'n'Bass-Track gehört hast, hast du gedacht, mein Gott, wie lange haben die da am Editing gesessen? Also du hast gehört, okay, es war vielleicht mal ein Amen Break, aber was aus dem rausgeholt wurde, hier ging mal die Snare runter, dann wurde hier was durchgefiltert, dann gingen die Hi-Hats irgendwie in die entgegengesetzte Richtung und so. Da waren schon ganz andere Techniken am Laufen irgendwie und das fand, also daraus hat sich ja auch eine Menge entwickelt, also später noch Tri-Pop-Sachen oder weiß nicht, bis heute zum Dubstep eigentlich. Ist das die Schule, wo man sagen muss, die haben wirklich meines Erachtens am meisten am Sound gearbeitet. Und Techno hatte sich dann irgendwie so, wie gesagt, bis zum Ende des Jahrtausends so entweder aufgelöst oder in diese Schranzrichtung und als Gegenbewegung gab es dann halt irgendwie so dieses Minimal, das ist auch schon immer so mitschwangen im Techno, aber so zum Ende des Jahrtausends als Gegenreaktion zu diesem Schranz wieder aufkam, so zum Beispiel Panorama war oder sowas. Unten lief halt, also damals Ostgut, unten lief halt weiterhin der harte Techno, solange es kein Schranz war, der ist in Berlin stattgefunden, aber auch harte Techno, so Luke Slater oder sowas. Damals auch André Galuzzi hat da aufgelegt. Und diese obere Etage hat dann sowas, als es früher der Chill-Out oder der Hausfloor war, hat das übernommen. Haus war ja auch an einem gewissen kommerziellen Ende angelangt, das ist ja auch eine Zeit lang Techno mitgelaufen, aber wurde dann halt irgendwie so, so ein Handtaschen-Haus, so ein Stuttgart-Haus.
Da sind ja noch so viele Aspekte, die ich gerne aufbrechen will. Vielleicht noch mal zu dieser internationalen Vernetzung. Du hast ja gesagt, so Mayday und so, da trafen dann irgendwie auch so die internationalen DJs zusammen. Ist ja auch grundsätzlich so, dass in vielen Clubs natürlich auch immer wieder reingefahren wurde. Jetzt hast du nochmal gesagt, die Berlin Detroit Connection. Inwieweit sind denn jetzt wirklich so internationale Freundschaften zwischen den DJs dann auch ausschlaggebend für die Weiterentwicklung gewesen? Bist du selber viel gereist eigentlich?
Ich bin viel gereist, aber ich war hauptsächlich deutschlandmäßig unterwegs, nähere Staaten in Deutschland. Ich war jetzt nicht so, der jetzt jedes Wochenende nach Japan oder nach Amerika gechattet ist. Also ich hatte meine Homebase hier hauptsächlich und bin auch hier meistens rumgereist und hab halt irgendwie so ganz deutschlandmäßig mitgekriegt, was sich verändert. Aber natürlich, also diese Deutschland-International- Connection hast du zum Beispiel nach Detroit gehabt über Tresor oder Hardwax, die sehr eng mit den Künstlern da immer verbunden waren.
Hardwax-Label?
Hardwax-Plattenladen. Die hatten halt irgendwie sehr viel, also dadurch, dass auch diese Basic-Channel-Sachen, die waren ja, Basic-Channel ist das Label von Hardwax bei den Plattenladen. Und das war ja auch schon so eine sehr berlinerische, also Mark Ernestus, der den Laden gehört, war auch ein sehr großer Reggae-Fan und hat dann versucht, halt so Reggae mit Techno zu vermischen, hat dabei so eine sehr eigene Variante davon entwickelt mit Moritz von Oswald zusammen, der heute jetzt, der macht heute mit Carl Craig, macht er zum Beispiel auch die Detroit Connection, hat er als letztes doch diese, glaube ich, den Bolero neu vertraut für deutsche Grammophon.
Techno-Bullero.
Das hat mir sehr gut gelungen.
Du bist ein Bullero-Fan, was dabei herausgekommen ist.
Für die deutsche Grammophon, die haben so eine Remix-Serie irgendwie, wo dann Techno-Artist halt die Sachen neu interpretieren.
Kick an. Also Techno ist eigentlich schon vollständig so auch im Gesamtkulturkreis Musik angekommen, kann man sagen. Vorhin so nebenbei, das wird jetzt keiner gehört haben, aber ich hab's gehört, du hast den Amen Break erwähnt. Das Ding ist ja nochmal so ein Phänomen für sich.
Genau, so wie der Apache Break.
Okay, den kenn ich jetzt nicht. Okay, der Amen Break ist, wenn ich es richtig erinnere, von, erinnerst du dich jetzt, wer das mal gemacht hat? Es war irgendeine Combo, ich schlag es mal kurz nach, damit man es hier auch mal zusammenhängt, erklären kann. Ein Mr. Coleman. Ja, aber die Combo. Also es war so ein Drum-Solo, ne?
Also so ein kurzer Break aus einem Drum-Solo.
Genau, das mal auf einer Platte veröffentlicht worden, auf der B-Seite. Und eigentlich hätte es keiner weiter zur Kenntnis genommen. Es war halt ein Lied von vielen Millionen Liedern, die in den letzten 100 Jahren mal erzeugt wurden. Aber dieser eine kurze Break, also wo sozusagen das Lied kurz aussetzt und wirklich nur das Drum-Solo spielt eben Can I Have an Amen oder so hieß glaube ich das Lied. Deswegen nannten wir diesen Amen Break und das ist im Prinzip die Vorlage für unzählige Generationen von Musikrichtungen. Breakbeat, was du erwähnt hast, eigentlich geht ja mehr oder weniger alles auf diesen einen Break zurück. Oder ist das jetzt schon ein bisschen zu weit ausgeholt?
Es ist halt der in der Jungle- und frühen Drum-Bass-Phase, das war der Sport unter den Produzern, aus diesem Break möglichst viel rauszuholen. Also der wurde zerlegt und zerhackt und neu zusammengesetzt und editiert und mit anderen Parts irgendwie vermischt. Das Ding ist mutiert ohne Ende. Also ich hab mich diesem Sport nicht angeschlossen. Der ist sehr englisch. Also diese Variante ist sehr englisch. Und ich war jetzt nie irgendwie da drauf, möglichst englisch. Ich hab immer versucht, mein eigenes Ding daraus zu holen. Und ich fand andere Breaks, zum Beispiel der Break, der bei Meet Bit Benefesto im Radio Babylon drin ist oder so, fand ich viel interessanter für mich eigentlich, weil er mir mehr entspricht.
Jetzt haben wir wieder an den Punkt angelangt, wo es sehr schwierig wird, bei einem reinen Gespräch über Musik irgendwas Sinnvolles rüberzubringen, weil sich jetzt alle schon am Kopf kratzen. Aber das kann man ja auch hier alles ganz locker nachschlagen. Es gibt gerade zu diesem Amen Break gibt's ein sehr schönes, erklärendes Video, das hatte ich ja auch mal auf ChaosTV gepostet. Findet ihr in den Links, wo so diese Geschichte dieses Amen Breaks und die ganzen Konsequenzen hervorgebracht hat, weil ja da auch so diese Copyright-Frage natürlich dahintersteht. Da wollte ich jetzt auch so ein bisschen darauf hinaus, wo du ja auch gesagt hast, der Drum und Bass ist so ein bisschen ein Techno davon marschiert, weil die immer noch so in ihren Synthesizerklängen dahingegangen sind. Und eigentlich geht ja jetzt alles mit Samplern. Also auch hier haben wir wieder so diese nächste Stufe von technologischer Entwicklung. Ein Sampler, das war noch so in den 90er Jahren, so irgendwie diese supertollen Geräte in der Lage waren, Audio zu speichern und dann irgendwie immer wieder von sich zu geben, während ja so ein Synthesizer ja noch, wie soll ich sagen, rein parametrisch irgendwie funktioniert hat.
Ja, da war halt immer der Streit irgendwie. Also der Sampler war halt irgendwie bei der einigen verpönt, weil damit kann ja jeder dann Musik machen. Und der Synthesizer, da musste sie ja noch selber programmieren lernen und dann ist es erst Musik. Also immer so dieses Ding, wenn man was selber machen muss, dann ist es erst was wirklich die wahre Kunst, so sehr deutsche Einstellungen meines Erachtens. Irgendwie ist es immer so, du musst schon im Schweiß in deinem Angesicht etwas tun, damit es gut wird irgendwie.
Aber weil der Synthesizer schon musste sich wahrscheinlich am Anfang genau den selben Vorwurf machen.
Ja, dann haben sie halt ein Preset genommen. Ich meine, ich habe es ja oft genug bei meinen Kollegen gesehen irgendwie. Ich war ja immer der Sampler-Unterstützer und dann haben sie mir erzählt irgendwie, wir müssen ja noch alles selber programmieren. Dann habe ich halt gesehen, wie sie ihre Presets aufrufen und dann irgendwie mal ein bisschen hier die Cutoff und die Frequenzen verdrehen und das war es dann schon irgendwie.
Im Schweiß ihres Angesichts.
Aber alles selber programmieren.
Kein Preset benutzt, alles verändert.
Aber so reinklanglich geht es jetzt sozusagen hin zum Sample, dass sozusagen das Sample selber zum Musikinstrument wird. Kann man das so sagen? Lass uns doch mal die musikalische Entwicklung in den nächsten 20 Jahren voraussagen. Das habe ich jetzt nicht gesagt.
Na also im Moment ist es irgendwie so dieses Hybride. Also einerseits, also seitdem die ganzen Sachen sowieso umrechner sind, erübrigt sich ja diese Diskussion eh ein bisschen, finde ich. Also früher war es halt immer noch diese Sache, welche Hardware kaufst du dir? Von daher war es natürlich eine existenzielle Frage, setzte eher auf den Synthesizer oder auf den Sampler. Mit dem Sampler hast du damals für 6000 Mark ein Gerät gehabt, mit dem konntest du eigentlich alles machen, wenn du genug Spuren hattest. Und bei einem Synthesizer war es halt so, der eine taugte eher für die Leads, der andere taugte eher für den Bass, der nächste taugte eher für die Flächen, aber du hattest nie wirklich so einen Teil irgendwie, mit dem du alles machen konntest. Gar ging es theoretisch, aber jeder hatte irgendwo seine Schwächen irgendwie. Und von daher war natürlich auch die Diskussion damals härter geführt worden. Heute ist es ein bisschen obsolet, weil wenn du jetzt eine Software kaufst wie Logic oder sowas, hast du 10-Sündigs drin und da hast du einen Sampler auch noch drin und irgendwie von daher streitet sich da heute, glaube ich, jetzt nicht mehr so viel, weil es kostet nicht mehr so viel.
Ja, wird richtig pettig, so ein Studio zu haben, wo man irgendwie noch vor kurzem 100.000 Euro ausgeben muss, um all diese ganzen Geräte zusammenzukaufen, kriegt man das heute einfach als Plug-in.
Ich habe damals einen Kredit aufgenommen von, glaube ich, 30.000 Mark und da ein Bruchteil hat alles Studios gehabt irgendwie. Und heute kaufst du dir einen Rechner, holst dir Ableton dazu und noch ein, zwei, drei, vier Softplugs irgendwie und hast eigentlich ein komplett perfektes Studio.
Da musst du ja überhaupt nichts mehr machen. Was ist denn das? Das ist doch keine Kunst mehr. Du musst mit dem Schweiß in deinem Angesicht deine Geräte ins Recht schrauben.
Es ist aber auch leider so, dass halt wirklich ganz schön viel Müll rauskommt.
Na klar, aber Kraftwerk hat eigentlich Recht behalten, würde ich da sagen. Jeder kann die frische Musik machen. Das heißt nicht, dass bei jedem was Gutes ist. Nein, klar, natürlich so ist es. Das ist ja auch mit Photoshop nicht anders. Jetzt kann ja jeder irgendwie Bilder malen, aber es ist nicht jeder einfach ein visueller Künstler. Das fand ich auch schon immer irgendwie so ein bisschen absurd. An letzten Endes denke ich, dass es gar kein Fehler ist, möglichst viele Hände die Werkzeuge zu geben, weil dann wird sich eh am Ende herausstellen, wer denn damit wirklich was anfangen kann. Die Masse macht es. Ja, aber es gibt immer so diese Angst davor. Aber wie geht es denn jetzt weiter mit den Musikern? Das haben wir schon mal besprochen, aber irgendwie interessiert mich das, weil es auch immer so eine komische konservative Front ist, auch in dieser ganzen Diskussion. Du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, einerseits brauchen wir kommerzielle Systeme, aber wir brauchen auch freie Systeme. Es zeigt sich ja auch, dass auch die Techno-Gemeinde auch in diesem Feld von Open Source Music oder Netlabels, dazu hatte ich hier auch schon mal ein längeres, ganz aufschlussreiches Gespräch, wo sich vor allem diese Minimal Techno-Szene am Anfang sehr breit gemacht hat. Ich weiß nicht, wie sich das mittlerweile entwickelt hat. Siehst du denn da irgendwie jetzt einen Trend? Also ist so dieses, wir sind im Netz, wir sind Labels im Netz, die Musik findet sich im Netz, entwickelt sich im Netz, ist das, zeichnet sich das ab, kommt das oder ändert sich eigentlich gar nicht so viel dadurch?
Ich finde, das ist ziemlich stehengeblieben. Also, man hängt da immer noch an einer Idee fest, und zwar irgendwie der des Netlabels. Und die Idee des Netlabels finde ich mittlerweile etwas überholt, weil das für mich immer so den Ruch hat, den auch so die ersten Synthesizer auf dem Rechner hatten. Und zwar hat man versucht, die Hardware zu emulieren in der Software. Und genauso kommt mir ein Netlabel auch vor. Sie versuchen, ein Hardware-Label im Netz zu emulieren. Und ich finde, das ist nicht mehr wirklich zeitgemäß. Und da sind die kommerziellen Anbieter schon weiter. Also, wenn ich jetzt auf BeatPod gucke oder für die ich arbeite, What People Play, da ist es gar nicht mehr so wichtig, auf welchem Label du bist, sondern du bist halt irgendwie verortet über Style, Artist.
Was sind das jetzt für Plattformen?
Da wo du mal Musik von Labels kaufen kannst. Da gibt es dann halt so, wie es früher einen Vertrieb gab, der an Plattenladen weitergegeben hat, gibt es heute halt den Vertrieb, der direkt mit dem Kunden irgendwie verbunden ist. Du gehst auf Beatport, das ist genauso wie der iTunes Music Store zum Beispiel.
Aber mehr so für die Untergrundmusik sozusagen.
Und da findest du halt die ganze Musik unter einem Anbieter. Während bei Netlabels ist es immer so, ich muss halt immer gucken, wer hat gerade wieder draus gebracht. Ich kriege teilweise die Labels gar nicht mit, die ich halt aber bei dem kommerziellen Anbieter irgendwie mitkriege. Weil ich kriege zum Beispiel, ach guck mal, der hat das und das geremixed, gucke ich einfach drauf, was hat er noch so gemacht. Irgendwie, und das finde ich bei Netlabels nicht. Da hat jeder seine eigene Insel, ohne die mal irgendwie miteinander connecten. Es gibt keine...
Okay, aber das ist ja mehr eine Frage des Distributionsweges.
Das ist für mich die Frage der Zukunft. Ich muss filtern können und ich muss finden können.
Aber was ist denn dann die Zukunft, dass ich zwei oder ein Store durchsetze und da gibt es dann alles? Das kannst du ja auch nicht sagen.
Nein, also für die Freien wünsche ich mir, dass dieser Netlabel-Gedanke mal einem Net-Audio-Gedanken weicht. Also Netlabel finde ich heute ein bisschen überflüssig. Also das Label hat jetzt nicht mehr den Stellenwert, den es früher mal hatte, wo du halt nach einem Label gegangen bist, das kaufe ich, weil da das und das rauskommt. Das sollte eher ein Net-Audio-Gedanke sein. Und ich will ein Dach sehen, wo das alles drunter passiert und nicht, ich will jetzt auf Netlabel A gucken, was haben die diese Woche rausgebracht? Ach, gar nichts, umsonst hingesurft. Also gehe ich jetzt zu Netlabel B und klappe die alle einzeln ab. Ich will das nicht mehr. Also das ist, wenn sich Open Source Musik weiterentwickeln will, dann müssen sie auch irgendwie ein gemeinsames Dach finden, wo ich die Sachen finden kann. Ansonsten kreplen die weiter vor sich hin. Und da warte ich schon seit Jahren eigentlich drauf.
Also im Prinzip da auch eine offene Plattform, sozusagen, die alles zusammenfasst.
Also ich muss finden und filtern können. Ich muss alles finden können, irgendwie wie es im kommerziellen Bereich auch. Also ich finde es traurig, dass der kommerzielle Bereich da weiter ist als dieser eigentlich netzerführende Netlabelbereich. Das finde ich ein bisschen traurig. Und ich habe da auch schon vor zwei oder drei Jahren mal einen Artikel drüber geschrieben und habe da auch von Netlabels teilweise Applaus für gekriegt. Dabei passiert nichts diesbezüglich. Also dann macht jeder weiter seine eigene Insel. Und ich habe jetzt auch nicht die Zeit, irgendwie jetzt jedes Netlabel auszuchecken, ob die jetzt was für mich sind oder sowas. Sondern ich brauche da schon irgendwie so eine Oberfläche, wo ich alles darunter finde irgendwie. Und dann sagen kann, heute gucke ich mir an, was ist neu rausgekommen bei Dubstep, morgen gucke ich mir an, was ist neu rausgekommen bei Techno. Und finde da drüber dann auch wieder neue Artists, die dazugekommen sind. Und das passiert bis jetzt nicht.
Aber die Musikentwicklung spielt sich im Netz ab. Das kann man schon sagen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Guck dir zum Beispiel Soundcloud an. Das sind ja auch wieder in Berlin, ne?
Das sind aber keine Berliner, ne? Welche Schweden oder so?
Ja, Schweden haben in Berlin gekommen. Aber es ist, finde ich zum Beispiel, eine sehr gute Plattform, um sich selber irgendwie mit Leuten, mit Musikern zu connecten, Musikern zu folgen, sowohl Leuten, die Plattenverträge haben oder auch völlig frei arbeiten und auch miteinander zu connecten und auch als Einstiegsbasis zum Beispiel für jemanden, der halt jetzt irgendwie, was früher Netlabel zum Beispiel übernommen hat, das war ja am Anfang irgendwie so, nicht so gedacht, ist aber dann auch dahin gegangen, dass Netlabel die Vorstufe zu einem Release sind irgendwie. Also es war ursprünglich nicht so gedacht, aber ist dann später doch so geworden, wenn du dann siehst, wie es der Film dann doch Platten rausgebracht haben. Und jetzt übernimmt meines Erachtens so Portale wie Soundcloud diese Funktion. Du musst nicht mehr an Label angeschlossen sein, oder du musst nicht mehr an irgendwas angeschlossen sein, um deine Musik rauszubringen. Du kannst es zum Beispiel über Soundcloud promoten, rausbringen, dich mit anderen connecten und darüber vielleicht dann ein Release hinkriegen oder auch, sei es auch nur, mit anderen connecten, die ähnlich gelagert sind, mit denen zusammen produzieren. Also das sind so die Vorstufen, wo ich mir denke, wo dann später halt, wo ich halt auch denke, dass in Zukunft wieder viel mehr die Kollaboration, also mein reines Gefühl, also allein schon von meinem Empfinden her, dass die Kollaboration in Zukunft wieder verstärkt stattfinden wird. Weil mir alleine geht es schon momentan auf dem Sender irgendwie, allein im Studio zu sitzen und vor mich hinzufrickeln, ohne eine Außeninspiration. Und ich glaube, dass das in Zukunft wieder vermehrt, weil die Technik jetzt auch mittlerweile so weit ist, dass Kollaborationen wieder viel mehr möglich sind. Sei es irgendwie, dass man noch einen Grafiker zunimmt, sei es, dass man zwei, drei Leute oder das einer, die Beats produziert, also so, wie es heute in einem kommerziellen Rahmen ja auch schon ist, das einer, die Beats produziert, der nächste ist der Synthesizer-Master oder ein Mastering-Ingenieur und so weiter. Das sowas auch im freien Umfeld wieder viel mehr verstärkt stattfindet. Allein der Inspiration wegen. Und auch vom Können her.
Cloud-Composing sozusagen. Man musiziert in der Wolke und...
Was früher mal irgendwie der Proberaum war, kann in Zukunft halt irgendwie ein virtueller Proberaum werden.
Gleich mit Chet und Wave und Wiki und was nicht alles. Bis hin zu der vollständigen Komposition im Netz. Ja, da rechne ich eigentlich auch mit. Bin gespannt. Vielleicht kommt ja noch mal irgendwas bei raus, was man dann nicht mehr Techno nennt. Ich glaube, das wird wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile halten. Tja, Tanith, haben wir irgendwas Entscheidendes vergessen? Also haben wir bestimmt, aber... Mir fällt jetzt auch nichts mehr ein, was ich noch unbedingt weiter vertiefen will. Insofern sage ich mal Danke.
Ich bedanke mich.
Für das ausführliche Gespräch hier über Techno und sein Wirken. Ich hoffe, da war ein bisschen was Neues dabei für euch. Das war dann Chaosradio Express 136. Es geht bald weiter. Es hätte eigentlich auch schon mal vorher eine Sendung geben sollen, aber wie das immer so ist, wenn wir mal frisch anfangen, dann fallen die Termine dann immer gleich wieder aus. Aber das Programm wird etwas dichter gestaffelt sein in der nahen Zukunft. Ja, insofern sage ich Tschüss. Du kannst auch nochmal Tschüss sagen.
See you on the dancefloor.